non
[Musique]
pourquoi vraiment d'hollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali a tourné un homme d'affaires ont
déjà réagi en homme comme femme tout le
monde et businessman est assez
impressionnant donc nollywood est
clairement le vent en poupe et les
budgets ce qui est gros budgets des
films à gros budget comme aux états unis
même en francs français
aujourd'hui le record de budget au
nigeria ces neuf millions de dollars et
monter en gamme
d'un point de vue technique au niveau
des histoires racontées etc
et du coup ça implique effectivement des
budgets beaucoup plus important donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent et
à beaucoup de pays en afrique
francophone notamment qui regarde ce
qu'est ce qu'on est gérée avec qui et
apprennent et qui essaye de faire pareil
en italie depuis le début de cette crise
en europe en tout cas fonctionne un peu
comme un laboratoire pour nous il faut
observer ce qui se passe là bas on va
nettement vers l'arrêt complet de
pratiquement le sport mondial
tous les clubs et tout les sports sont
pas affectés de la même façon les gros
résisteront beaucoup mieux que les
petits une fois qu'on aura des sportifs
humains qui y seront contaminés comme ça
peut être le coeur dans le cyclisme
les choses seront encore différent
qu'est ce qu'on fera quand on aura une
équipe qui sera atteinte
entièrement aux pinces ils se
transmettent etc au fil du temps si ça
continue le sport avant mur est-ce que
c'est grave
non ce qui est grave c'est qu'il y ait
des morts c'était les gens contaminés
c'est qu'ils aient des économies qui
sont susceptibles de s'effondrer le
sport n'est que du sport
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission émission
consacrée exclusivement à la crise du
coronavirus emmanuel macron va
s'adresser dans quelques instants aux
français sur cette crise sanitaire sans
précédent
une deuxième prise de parole en l'espace
de quatre jours une allocution
solennelle pour annoncer la suite des
événements est peut-être le passage au
confinement total en france alors que le
nombre de cas ne cesse d'augmenter de
manière inquiétante l'organisation
mondiale de la santé appelle quand elle
a effectué un test pour chaque cas
suspect
[Musique]
le g7 qui s'est tenu un sommet
extraordinaire par visioconférence
aujourd'hui évoque une tragédie humaine
et plaide pour une coordination sur la
gestion des frontières alors que
l'espagne elle annonce la fermeture de
ses frontières terrestres
le bilan de l'épidémie dépasse les 7000
personnes dans le monde dont 2158 rien
qu en italie selon un tout dernier bilan
ce soir les membres du g7 qui se sont
dits déterminés à faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour restaurer la croissance
mondiale alors qu'une fois de plus les
bourses sont en chute libre paris new
york/francfort c'était la dégringolade
aujourd'hui
venez vous
l'émission donc spéciale consacrée à
cette crise sanitaire liée aux
coronavirus le chef de l'état va
s'exprimer dans quelques instants à 20
heures précisément pour peut-être
annoncé le passage au confinement total
de tout le pays alors que 16 donc
d'augmenter et de se propager cette
épidémie est alors que s'est tenue le
1er tour des municipales hier allocution
à la suite donc d'un déjeuner avec les
membres du conseil de défense selon
l'elysée qui se sont réunis donc à 17
heures le chef de l'état qui a reçu les
présidents de l'assemblée nationale et
celui du sénat
et on va donc aller à l'elysée écouter
emmanuel macron en direct donc on me dit
que on me dit que voilà s'attardent un
petit peu on va retrouver le chef de
l'état dans quelques instants pour cette
allocution en attendant on va voir ce
qu'en pensent les français qui peu
présent d'ailleurs cet après midi aux
abords des champs elysées
si on vit que je peux tu sortir de chez
moi je reste chez moi
tout simplement donc après je sais
qu'ils vont ouvrir la possibilité de
faire des courses de proximité voilà
place au direct on écoute emmanuel
macron françaises français mes chers
compatriotes jeudi soir je me suis
adressé à vous pour évoquer la crise
sanitaire que traverse notre pays
jusqu'à lors l'épidémie de covile 19
étaient peut-être pour certains d'entre
vous une idée lointaine elle est devenue
une réalité immédiate pressante
le gouvernement a pris comme je vous
l'avais annoncé des dispositions fermes
pour freiner la propagation du virus
les crèches les écoles les collèges les
lycées les universités sont fermées
depuis ce jour samedi soir les
restaurants les bars tous les commerces
non essentiels à la vie de la nation
sont également clos leurs portes
les rassemblements de plus de 100
personnes ont été interdits
jamais la france n'avait dû prendre de
telles décisions
évidemment exceptionnel évidemment
temporaire en temps de paix elles ont
été prises avec ordre préparation sur la
base de recommandations scientifiques
avec un seul objectif nous protéger face
à la propagation du virus dans la
journée de jeudi
un consensus scientifique et politique
s'est formé pour maintenir le premier
tour des élections municipales et j'ai
pris avec le premier ministre
la décision de maintenir le scrutin
hier dimanche les opérations de vote ont
donc pu se tenir
je veux ce soir remercié les services de
l'état les maires l'ensemble des
services des mairies tous ceux qui ont
tenu les bureaux de vote et qui ont donc
permis l'organisation de ce scrutin
je veux aussi saluer chaleureusement les
françaises et les français qui malgré le
contexte se sont rendus aux urnes dans
le strict respect
des consignes sanitaires des gestes
barrières contre le virus je veux aussi
ce soir adresser mes félicitations
républicaines au candidat élu au premier
tour
environ trente mille communes sur 35
mille ont après ce premier tour un
conseil municipal mais dans le même
temps alors même que les personnels
soignants des services de réanimation
alerter sur la gravité de la situation
nous avons aussi vu du monde se
rassembler dans les parcs des marchés
bondés des restaurants des bars qui
n'ont pas respecté la consigne de
fermeture comme si au fond la vie
n'avait pas changé à tout ce qui
adoptant ces comportements ont bravé les
consignes je veux dire ce soir très
clairement non seulement vous ne vous
protégez pas vous et l'évolution récente
a montré que personne n'est invulnérable
et compris les plus jeunes mais vous ne
protégez pas les autres même si vous ne
présentait aucun symptôme
vous pouvez transmettre le virus même si
vous ne présentait aucun symptôme vous
risquer de contaminer vos amis vos
parents vos grands parents de mettre en
danger la santé de ceux qui vous sont
chers dans le grand est
dans les hauts de france en ile de
france
nos soignants se bat pour sauver des
vies avec dévouement avec force au
moment où la situation sanitaire se
dégrade fortement où la pression sur nos
hôpitaux et nos soignants s'accentue
tout notre engagement
toute notre énergie toute notre force
doivent se concentrer sur un seul
objectif ralentir la progression du
virus
je vous le redis avec force ce soir
respectons les gestes barrières les
consignes sanitaires
c'est le seul moyen de protéger les
personnes vulnérables d'avoir moins de
concitoyens infectés et ainsi de réduire
la pression sur les services de
réanimation pour qu'ils puissent mieux
accueillir mieux soigner sans signes
graves contactons notre médecin traitant
n'appelons
le samu et ne nous rendons à l'hôpital
qu'en cas de forte fièvre de difficultés
à respirer sans quoi ils ne pourront
faire face à la vague de cas graves qui
déjà se profile dans certaines régions
faisons preuve au fond d'esprit
solidaire et de sens des responsabilités
chacun d'entre nous doit à tout prix
limiter le nombre de personnes avec qui
il est en contact chaque jour les
scientifiques le disent c'est la
priorité absolue c'est pourquoi après
avoir consulté écouter les experts le
terrain et en conscience j'ai décidé de
renforcer encore les mesures pour
réduire nos déplacements et nos contacts
au strict nécessaire dès demain midi et
pour quinze jours au moins nos
déplacements seront très fortement
réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promener retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
il s'agit de limiter au maximum ses
contacts au delà du foyer partout sur le
territoire français en métropole comme
outre-mer seules doivent demeurer les
trajets nécessaire nécessaire pour aller
faire ses courses avec de la discipline
et en mettant les distance d'au moins un
mètre en ne serrant pas la main en
embrassant pas les trajets nécessaire
pour se soigner
évidemment les trajets nécessaire pour
aller travailler quand le travail à
distance n'est pas possible et les
trajets nécessaires pour faire un peu
d'activité physique mais sans retrouver
là encore des amis ou des proches toutes
les entreprises doivent s'organiser pour
faciliter le travail à distance et quand
cela ne sera pas possible
elles devront adapter dès demain leur
organisation
pour faire respecter ces gestes barrière
contre le virus c'est à dire protéger
leurs salariés ou quand il s'agit d'
indépendants se protéger même le
gouvernement précisera les modalités de
ces nouvelles règles dès ce soir
d après mon allocution toute infraction
à ces règles sera sanctionné je vous le
dis avec beaucoup de solennité ce soir
écoutons les soignants qui nous disent
si vous voulez nous aider il faut rester
chez vous et limiter les contacts c'est
le plus important
évidemment ce soir je pose des règles
nouvelles nous posons des interdits il y
aura des contrôles mais la meilleure
règle c'est celle qu'en tant que citoyen
vous vous appliquez à vous même et une
fois encore j'en appelle à votre sens
des responsabilités et de la solidarité
dans ce contexte après avoir consulté le
président du sénat le président de
l'assemblée nationale mais également mes
prédécesseurs j'ai décidé que le second
tour des élections municipales serait
reporté le premier ministre en a informé
aujourd'hui même les chefs de partis
représentés au parlement
cette décision a fait l'objet d'un
accord unanime
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes je mesure
l'impact de toutes ses décisions sur vos
vies renoncé à voir ses proches
c'est un déchirement stopper ses
activités quotidiennes ses habitudes
c'est très difficile cela ne doit pas
nous empêcher de garder le lien
d'appeler nos proches de donner des
nouvelles d'organiser aussi les choses
avec nos voisins d'inventer de nouvelles
solidarités entre générations de rester
comme je voulais dit jeudi dernier
profondément solidaire et d'innover là
aussi sur ce point je sais que je vous
demande de rester
chez vous je vous demande aussi de
garder le calme
dans ce contexte j'ai vu ces dernières
heures des phénomènes de panique en tous
sens
nous devons tous avoir l'esprit de
responsabilité il faut pas que les
fausses informations circulent à tout va
et en restant chez vous occupez vous des
proches qui sont dans votre appartement
votre maison donner des nouvelles
prenait des nouvelles
li vé retrouvez aussi ce sens de
l'essentiel
je pense que c'est important dans les
moments que nous vivons la culture
l'éducation le sens des choses est
important et éviter l'esprit de panique
de croire dans toutes les fausses
rumeurs
les demis experts les faux sachant la
parole est clair l'information est
transparente et nous continuerons de
l'année mais croyez moi cet effort que
je vous demande
je sais qu'il est inédit mais les
circonstances nous y oblige nous sommes
en guerre en guerre sanitaire certes
nous luttons n'est contre une armée
n'est contre une autre nation mais
l'ennemi est là invisible insaisissable
qui progresse et cela requiert notre
mobilisation générale
nous sommes en guerre
toute l'action du gouvernement et du
parlement doit être désormais tournés
vers le combat contre l'épidémie
de jour comme de nuit rien ne doit nous
en divertir
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé que toutes
les réformes en cours seraient suspendus
à commencer par la réforme des retraites
dès mercredi en conseil des ministres
sera présenté un projet de loi
permettant au gouvernement de répondre à
l'urgence
et lorsque nécessaire de légiférer par
ordonnance dans les domaines relevant
strictement de la gestion de crise ce
projet sera soumis au parlement dès
jeudi
j'ai vu tout à l'heure les présidents de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat afin
que ce texte soit voté le plus
rapidement possible afin aussi que la
vie démocratique et le contrôle du
parlement continue dans cette période je
les en remercie et je remercie tous nos
parlementaires en cet instant nous
sommes en guerre
j'appelle tous les acteurs politiques
économiques sociaux associatifs tous les
français à s'inscrire dans cette union
nationale qui a permis à notre pays de
surmonter tant de crises par le passé
nous sommes en guerre et la nation
soutiendra ses enfants qui personnel
soignant en ville à l'hôpital se trouve
en première ligne dans un combat qui va
leur demander énergie détermination
solidarité ils ont des droits sur nous
nous leur devons évidemment les moyens
la protection nous serons là nous leur
devons des masques du gel tout le
matériel nécessaire et nous y veillons
et y veilleront nous avons décidé avec
les scientifiques de réserver les
masques en priorité pour l'hôpital et
pour la médecine de ville et de campagne
en particulier les généralistes les
infirmières désormais en première ligne
aussi dans la gestion de la crise des
masques seront livrés dans les
pharmacies dès demain soir dans les 25
départements les plus touchés mercredi
pour le reste du territoire national
j'ai aussi entendu le message des
spécialistes en particulier les
chirurgiens dentistes et beaucoup
d'autres des solutions seront trouvées
avec le ministre de la santé dans les
prochaines heures
nous devons aussi aux soignants la garde
de leurs enfants
un service minimum de garde est en place
depuis ce jour dans les crèches et dans
les écoles nous leur devons aussi
sérénité dans leurs déplacements et
repos
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé que dès
demain les taxis et les hôtels pourront
être mobilisés à leur profit l'état
paiera nous sommes en guerre
oui le pays
accompagnera dans cette période les
régions les plus touchées aujourd'hui
comme celles qui le seront demain
à ce titre je veux assurer les habitants
les personnels soignants du grand test
que nous serons au rendez vous pour les
appuyer
face à l'afflux de patients et à la
saturation des hôpitaux
je sais ce qu'ils vivent depuis des
jours et des jours
nous sommes avec eux j'ai décidé pour
cela qu'un hôpital de campagne du
service de santé des armées seraient
déployés dans les jours à venir en
alsace les armes et apporteront aussi
leur concours pour déplacer les malades
des régions les plus affectées et ainsi
réduire la congestion des hôpitaux de
certains territoires
nous sommes en guerre aussi comme je
voulais dit jeudi pour nous protéger et
contenir la dissémination du virus mais
aussi préserver nos systèmes de soins
nous avons pris ce matin entre européens
une décision commune dès demain midi les
frontières à l'entrée de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen
seront fermés concrètement tous les
voyages entre les pays non européens et
l'union européenne seront suspendues
pendant 30 jours
les françaises et les français qui sont
actuellement à l'étranger et souhaite
rentrer pourront bien entendu rejoindre
leur pays
nous devons prendre cette décision parce
que je vous demande ce soir d'importants
efforts et que nous devons dans la durée
nous protéger et je veux dire à tous nos
compatriotes qui vivent à l'étranger que
là aussi en bon ordre
ils doivent se rapprocher des ambassades
et consulats et que nous organiserons
pour celles et ceux qui le souhaitent
et là où c'est nécessaire
le rapatriement vous l'aurez compris
vous le présentez cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent aura des conséquences
humaines sociales économiques majeures
c'est aussi ce défi que nous devons
mener
je vous demande des sacrifices pour
ralentir l'épidémie
jamais ils ne doivent mettre en cause
l'aide aux plus fragiles la pérennité
d'une entreprise les moyens de
subsistance des salariés comme des
indépendants pour les plus précaires
pour les plus démunis pour les personnes
isolées
nous ferons en sorte avec les grandes
associations avec aussi les
collectivités locales et leurs services
qu'ils puissent être nourri protégés que
les services que nous leur devons soit
assurée pour la vie économique
pour ce qui concerne la france
aucune entreprise quelle que soit sa
taille ne sera livré au risque de
faillite
aucune française aucun français ne sera
laissée sans ressources
s'agissant des entreprises nous mettons
en place un dispositif exceptionnel de
reports de charges fiscales et sociales
de soutien report d'échéances bancaires
et de garanties de l'état à hauteur de
300 milliards d'euros pour tous les
prêts bancaires contractés auprès des
banques pour les plus petites d'entre
elles étant que la situation dure à
celles qui font face à des difficultés
n'auront rien à débourser
ni pour les impôts ni pour les
cotisations sociales les factures d'eau
de gaz ou d'électricité ainsi que les
loyers devront être suspendus
en outre afin que personne ne soit
laissé sans ressources pour les salariés
le dispositif de chômage partiel sera
massivement élargie comme je vous
l'avais annoncé jeudi dernier
et comme le gouvernement a commencé à le
préciser pour les entrepreneurs
commerçants artisans
un fonds de solidarité sera créé abondé
par l'état et auquel le premier ministre
proposera aux régions aussi de
contribuer le gouvernement dès demain
précisera toutes ces mesures elles
seront en fonction des besoins des
réalités économiques des nécessités
secteur par secteur
évidemment adapté nous serons au rendez
vous pour que notre économie soit
préservée dans cette période si dur et
pour que l'ensemble les travailleuses
des travailleurs puissent avoir cette
sécurité aussi en termes de pouvoir
d'achat de continuité de leur vie mes
chers compatriotes la france vit un
moment très difficile
nul ne peut en prévoir précisément la
durée et à mesure que les jours suivront
les jours que les problèmes succéderont
au problème il faudra en lien avec les
éclairages donné par les scientifiques
des expériences de terrain il faudra
nous adapter nous allons continuer aussi
pendant cette période de travail et de
progresser sur les traitements et je
sais le dévouement de plusieurs équipes
partout sur notre territoire avec des
premiers espoirs qui naissent et nous
continuerons aussi d'avancer sur le
vaccin
régulièrement je m'adresserai à vous je
vous dirai à chaque fois comme je lé
fais comme le gouvernement le fait la
vérité sur l'évolution de la situation
j'ai une certitude
plus nous agirons ensemble et vite
plus nous surmonterons cette épreuve
plus nous agirons en citoyen plus nous
ferons preuve de la même force d'âme de
la même abnégation patriotes que
démontre aujourd'hui nos personnels
soignants nos sapeurs pompiers
l'ensemble des acteurs de la sécurité
civile plus vite nous sortirons de cette
vie au ralenti
nous y arriverons mes chers compatriotes
en étant unie solidaire
je vous demande d'être responsables tous
ensemble et de ne céder à aucune panique
d'accepter ces contraintes de les porter
de les expliquer de vous les appliquez à
vous mêmes nous nous les appliquerons
tous
il n'y aura pas de passe-droit mais là
aussi de ne céder ni à la panique ni au
désordre
nous gagnerons
mais cette période nous aura beaucoup
appris beaucoup de certitudes de
conviction sont balayées seront remises
en cause beaucoup de choses que nous
pensions impossible advienne
ne nous laissons pas impressionner
agissons avec force mais retenons cela
le jour d'après quand nous aurons gagné
ce ne sera pas un retour au jour d'avant
nous serons plus fort moralement nous
aurons appris et je serai aussi avec
vous en tirer toutes les conséquences
toutes les conséquences
ils sont nous individuellement et
collectivement à la hauteur du moment je
sais mes chers compatriotes pouvoir
compter sur vous vive la république vive
la france
et voilà pour la locution d'emmanuel
micron qui a duré une vingtaine de
minutes longue allocution du président
de la république qui a appelé à
proscrire les déplacements limités donc
tous les contacts pour 15 jours au
minimum seuls les trajets nécessaire
pour aller se faire soigner ou pour
travailler quand cela est vraiment
nécessaire sont autorisés travailler
quand le travail à distance ça n'est pas
possible toujours privilégié le
télétravail a dit emmanuel macron qui
appelle les entreprises à s'organiser en
ce sens le second tour des municipales
qui a donc été reportés ainsi que la
réforme des retraites pour plus de
détails
on va retrouver dans quelques instants
notre reporter et celle farges à
l'elysée en attendant premières
réactions celle de didier maïsto
président de sud radio bonsoir didier
maïsto merci d'être en direct avec nous
vous avez donc suivi l'allocution
d'emmanuel macron première impression
globale écoutez la première impression
globale est bonne je trouve que lui-même
cic et il était temps à la hauteur de la
situation
il était sobre sur la forme juste sur le
fond et je pense que l'heure est à
l'union nationale et il l'a sweeney
lui-même un effort individuel et annie
un effort collectif pour se hisser à la
bonne hauteur cette situation tout à
fait exceptionnelle et donc ce soir et
je pense le discours qu israël est
prononcée et les discours qu'il fallait
que tout le monde entende pour que
chacun prenne la mesure et fassent
preuve de responsabilité dans ses
déplacements
parce que parfois on n'a pas
l'impression d'y échapper
on a l'impression nous mêmes que nous ne
sommes pas atteint mais nous sommes un
facteur de propagation parce que le
virus ne circule pas dans l'absolu ce
sont les personnes humaines qui te font
circuler
donc ce soir c'était vraiment le
discours qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
prononcé donc c'était avec moi
d'ailleurs sur ce bateau avec nous lors
du dernier discours des manuels latron
vous aviez été
assez sévère à son encontre qu'est-ce
qui a fait que là pour vous il ya un
changement plutôt positif à vos yeux
disons que dans le premier discours d'il
ya quelques jours il était écouté parler
et il l'avait annoncé il avait parlé
pour ne rien dire pour partir grand
chose c'était la montagne qui avait
accouché d'une souris
je pense que lui-même soit il n'avait
pas pris la mesure des événements et de
la situation ce qui était quand même un
petit peu inquiétant soit ce qui l'était
tout autant
at il voulu instrumentaliser la
temporalité le teint tôt parce que
évidemment il y avait l'élection
municipale ce qui était un pur scandale
d'organiser cette élection municipale
puisque ensuite lui-même mais tout
l'exécutif et un certain nombre
pratiquement tous les chefs de partis
ont ont proclamé que c'était bien
organisé
ce qui est une hérésie on n'envoie pas
des millions de gens voter et se balader
dans l'état bien sûr tout le monde
alliés après c'était les parcs mais les
parcs c'était un succédané c'était autre
chose c'était en plus il fallait que les
gens restent confinés ce qu'on peut
évidemment regretter c'est que ce
discours
s'il avait été prononcée il y a trois
semaines tout le monde aurait applaudi
et là évidemment c'était bien le moins
que l'on puisse faire de rattraper
autant que possible le temps perdu
le temps perdu ne se rattrape jamais
tout à fait parce que si vous voulez
avec ce qui s'est passé dimanche comme
il ya une période d'incubation qui est
moyenne étant de 14 jours nous allons
avoir un pic énorme parce que dans 14
jours parce que tout le monde en se
déplaçant sans en avoir conscience
horace et exploser la courbe et les
nombre de contaminés et ça c'était tout
à fait scandaleux on a vu on a vécu hier
une journée lunaire est complètement
surréaliste c'était criminel donc
aujourd'hui c'était bien le moins
d'essayer de rattraper de rattraper les
choses et et enfin pour la première fois
pour la première fois de son quinquennat
il est apparu à la hauteur de sa
fonction maintenant il faut que ce soit
suicidé c'est parce que monsieur macron
est un très grand acteur
de théâtre donc là il faut il a prononcé
un discours c'est très bien l'heure est
à l'union nationale ne faut pas
polémiquer
parce que ceux qui vont polémiquer ce
soir par rapport à ce qui a été dit ce
soir seront disqualifiés parce que
maintenant tout le monde doit faire cet
effort et d'efforts qui a été annoncé du
pur pour l'état de la part de l'état est
conséquent il faut quand même avoir dans
l'esprit que l'état c'est vous c'est moi
c'est nous tous mais de toute façon
c'est nous qui paierons tout le monde
paiera mais pour l'instant il faut il
faut passer ce cap difficile et c'est
très bien d'avoir suspendu tous les
textes en course est très bien avoir
suspendu la réforme des retraites
et c'est très bien d'avoir rappelé les
gestes d'élémentaire qui au bout du bout
vont sauver des vies mais effectivement
ce que l'on peut regretter et regretter
amèrement quand même c'est le retard à
l'allumage c'est trois semaines qui nous
font défaut et qui aujourd'hui nous
conduisent à cette situation
je rappelle et lui même l'a dit qui
tirerait tous les enseignements
je rappelle quand même que sur beaucoup
puisqu'on est sur une chaîne de télé de
chaînes même ce crime n'est pas sans la
vôtre parce qu'on a toujours pu parler
en toute liberté et je tiens à le signer
d'ailleurs céline est rare télé dans
laquelle je m'exprime on a eu beaucoup
deux experts en bois de pseudo
scientifiques qui sont des millions
d'euros à la une de magazines en se
prétendant médecin et je citerai pas de
noms parce que ça serait trop cruel et
qu'encore une fois l'heure n'est pas à
la polémique mais ces gens là ont une
lourde responsabilité dans la situation
qui nous expliquait il ya encore une
semaine que c'était une petite gripette
et que dans quatre jours après quelques
degrés de fièvre nous serons remis sur
pied et donc là eh oui il y aura
beaucoup d'enseignements à tirer sur
l'union européenne à fait sûr sur la
dépendance à la chine sur le
protectionnisme et les frontières au
sens large comme au sens strict et sur
ces médias meanstream qui qui dispensent
d'aider des discours et qui donne des
conseils qui sont des concerts des
conseils qui amène les gens à halle
justement vous pariez de frontières
cette mesure fermeture de tous les pays
des frontières de tous les pays de
l'union européenne pour 30 jours sauf
évidemment pour les français qui
voudront revenir deux pays'' étrangères
va ça n'arrive pas trop tard selon vous
ben c'est toujours trop tard mais si
vous voulez on va pas rajouter du
désordre et c'est pas parce qu'on est en
retard qu'il faut pas prendre le toit en
mars si on arrive à prendre le train en
marche et limiter un tant soit peu la
propagation du virus puisque aujourd'hui
les spécialistes le savez très long dit
l'épicentre de ces virus
c'est c'est vraiment l'europe il faut
limiter
évidemment la propagation de ces virus
parce que de toute façon le virus n'ont
pas de frontières ça c'est très clair il
faut pas jouer sur les mots mais en
limitant les piles et évidemment les
déplacements on va limiter aussi la
pandémie et ne pas contaminer d'autres
continents il faut maintenant être
sérieux on a bien compris le message
vous pensez que ce sont des bonnes
mesures un bon discours avait souligné
effectivement le report à l'abandon en
tout cas temporaire des textes notamment
la réforme des retraites que vous
combattiez comme de nombreux français
d'ailleurs il n'empêche beaucoup de
rumeurs à ses assurés
d'ailleurs faisait part d'un confinement
total comme en italie
le président n'a pas semblé l'annoncé on
aura les détails avec le gouvernement
c'est une demi mesure pour vous on vous
l'avez compris comment non je pense que
déjà la relève qui se place donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans la
riposte graduée et je vous avez vu comme
le touloulou les français aujourd'hui
que certain nombre de nos compatriotes
ont pris en pleine face la réalité le
réel et ont changé leur comportement
petit à petit les entreprises se sont
vidés et tout le monde a joué le jeu
les transports en commun se sont vidés
et le pays va s'arrêter progressivement
je pense que les pouvoirs publics ont
fait le choix
de laisser aux français le temps de
s'organiser de quitter évidemment dans
des circonstances un peu un peu organisé
leur lieu de travail pour peut-être
aller dans le temps des maisons
familiales on pourra être plus en
sécurité
essayez de ne pas se concentrer dans des
îles qui sont des nids forcément à virus
1 puisque c'est bien beau de de dire de
respecter la distance de sécurité
mais quand vous prenez et qu'on n'avait
pas le choix un transport en commun que
vous êtes collés les uns contre les
autres c'est un facteur de propagation
du virus donc je pense que ce délai
c'est un délai raisonnable c'était un
coup de vis assez important et je pense
que on n'est pas complètement la fin du
processus et que évidemment je pense
qu'il fera d'autres annoncé qu on ira
vers le confinement total mais ça permet
de ne pas à augmenter la panique vous
avez vu les files d'attentes aujourd'hui
dans les supermarchés et cetera parce
que là nous sommes dans l'irrationnel et
moins un peuple et préparer surtout
quand vous avez des médias qui toute la
journée leur dise que tout va bien
le gibus est intelligent et que les
français sont plus intelligents que les
autres peuples parce qu'ils ont des
barrières naturelles fait de neurones
fait de neurones donc qui empêche le
délai se soit propagé donc vous prenez
en compte de plein fouet le réel et donc
qu'il ya eu une espèce de réaction de
terreur voire de panique et de désarroi
donc il faut laisser ce temps mais je
pense que ça va aller très vite
maintenant on va voir ce qui va se
passer demain
il a donné jusqu'à midi et je pense que
c'est clair les jambons vont comprendre
enfin j'espère ce qui nous manque ce qui
est en train de nous arriver
mais effectivement si la communication
dès le début et si on avait passé de
politique politicienne pour tenir ces
satanés élections municipales dans tout
le monde savait que c'était un scandale
et dont tout le monde savait qu'il n'y
aurait pas de participation et dont tout
le monde savait que nous serions obligés
et contraints de les annuler pour la
bonne et simple raison
on serait dans le train dans la montée
du pic pour le deuxième tour
c'était tout à fait irresponsable donc
ça c'était un regret parce que au bout
du bout ça va faire des victimes
non pas parce que le virus même s'il est
très virulent et mortelle mais parce que
dans des cas sévères
on a besoin de respirateurs on a besoin
d'être un tube et on a besoin de vie et
que les capacités sont évidemment même
si elles sont importantes elles sont pas
un chiffre tout le monde doit le
comprendre
merci beaucoup didier maïsto président
de sud radio nous avoir apporté vos
premières impressions après cette
allocution d'emmanuel macron qui a duré
un peu plus de 20 minutes et on va
retrouver notre reporter estelle farges
qui se trouve devant l'elysée celle vous
avez donc suivi ce discours que faut-il
en retenir dans les détails
nous sommes en guerre sanitaire a
martelé le chef de l'état dans son
allocution une allocution d'une
vingtaine de minutes pendant laquelle
emmanuel macron a annoncé de nouvelles
mesures donc pour lutter contre
l'épidémie de qu'on a virus je vous
demande des sacrifices pour ralentir
l'épidémie a déclaré le chef de l'état
il a commencé à par ap les premières
mesures qui avaient été prises jeudi
dernier le chef de l'état qui a déploré
que certains français n'est pas respecté
à les gestes barrières et les consignes
sanitaires dès demain midi des consignes
plus strictes seront donc appliqué à les
réunions amicales les réunions
familiales tout cela ne sera plus
possible les déplacements seront
fortement réduits
je vous proposais ce propos les qte et
emmanuel macron j'ai décidé de renforcer
encore les mesures pour réduire nos
déplacements et nos contacts au strict
nécessaire dès demain midi et pour
quinze jours au moins nos déplacements
seront très fortement réduit cela
signifie que les regroupements extérieur
les réunions familiales ou amicales ne
seront plus permises se promet retrouver
ses amis dans le parc dans la rue ne
sera plus possible
il s'agit de limiter au maximum ses
contacts au delà du foyer partout sur le
territoire français en métropole comme
outre-mer seules doivent demeurer les
trajets nécessaire nécessaire pour aller
faire ses courses avec de la discipline
et en mettant les distance d'au moins un
mètre en ne serrant pas la main en
embrassant pas les trajets nécessaire
pour se soigner
évidemment les trajets nécessaire pour
aller travailler quand le travail à
distance n'est pas possible et les
trajets nécessaires pour faire un peu
d'activité physique mais sans retrouver
là encore des amis ou des proches alors
le gouvernement et qui devraient
préciser les modalités d'application de
celle de cette nouvelle ces nouvelles
dans la soirée le chef de l'état a
prévenu toute infraction sera puni enfin
emmanuel macron a déclaré que le second
tour des élections municipales serait
bien évidemment reporter toutes les
réformes en cours seront suspendus
merci estelle farges en direct donc de
l'elysée vous avez suivi comme nous tous
d'ailleurs le discours d' emmanuel
macron autres réactions en direct cette
fois ci avec arnaud benedetti rédacteur
en chef de la revue politique et
parlementaire bonsoir arnaud benedetti
d'être avec nous un discours assez long
avec une rhétorique qui reviennent
revenez plusieurs fois nous sommes en
guerre
witt une rhétorique solennelle une
rhétorique martial le président de la
république a voulu et a fixé sur la
gravité des moments que la société était
en train de traverser
c'était si vous voulez un discours qui
d'abord cherché à justifier sa première
intervention et puis surtout à décliner
le nouvelles mesures qui sont plus
contraignantes pour l'ensemble des
françaises et des français notamment en
matière de déplacements en l'occurrence
on s'attendait plutôt à près tout ce que
l'on pouvait finalement voir fuité
depuis le début de la journée à des
mesures certainement beaucoup plus
encore coercitive de clips italienne on
est dit long sur une position qui était
intermédiaire manifestement qui n'est
pas tout à fait la position que nos
voisins italiens ont adopté mais qui
bien évidemment refaire les contraintes
sur notamment les déplacements des
françaises et des français sur les
conditions de deux villes de vie
quotidienne et on attend maintenant bien
évidemment parce que c'est plus
important les modalités d'application et
on revient que le président de la
république laisse le soin à son premier
mini que d'annoncer ses modalités
d'application ressemble ou encore qu'ils
viennent comment vous avez trouvé la
tonalité justement
discours didier maïsto ses critiques
envers le président de la république ne
disait que c'était une bonne réponse
mais effectivement vous faisiez allusion
à ce confinement total qui semblait être
la solution choisie par le gouvernement
qui ne l'a finalement pas été pour vous
c'est une demi mesure où c'est une bonne
chose peut-être de ne pas contraintes
trop les français
d'un seul coup écoutez sur un plan
sanitaire moi je ne suis pas en mesure
de vous répondre seuls les scientifiques
et les médecins sont sont capables
aujourd'hui d'apporter des réponses
au vu de ce qu'ils connaissent à la fois
du virus et de la propagation de ce de
ce virus ce qui est sûr c'est que il a
vraisemblablement il n'a pas voulu vous
n'êtes pas vraiment prendre des mesures
hyper contraignantes qui soit 10 ont
perçu qu'on me bruts alors est-ce que
c'était la hauteur de l'épidémie ça seul
l'avenir nous le dira mais il est clair
que on a vu un président de la
république a une tonalité extrêmement
grave encore une fois extrêmement
martial répétant à plusieurs reprises
nous sommes en guerre certains d'entre
eux auront peut-être que même cette
sémantique est un club pour souffler au
regard de la situation historique elle
était véritablement pétiste en
l'occurrence mais il a voulu
vraisemblement est et sur le fait que
nous étions dans un contexte qui
nécessité de prendre des mesures
beaucoup plus contraignante que les
premières mesures qui va annoncer jeudi
dernier encore une fois moi je pense que
là le final en le grand enseignement
qu'il faut retenir de ce discours
surtout c'est vrai simplement la
fléchissement politique il est en train
de donner à son mandat je crois qu'il ya
quelque chose d'absolument essentiel qui
a été dit par le président de la
république et qui va interroger d'un
évidemment les commentateurs et des
acteurs politiques et que les réformes
en cours sont suspendues et là en effet
il s'agit d'une annonce qui pour le coup
extrêmement précise et tu eu
indéniablement vient changer en tout cas
l'atome politique dans ce pays
justement on avait dit que j'allais y
venir évidemment cette inflexion
politique
report de beaucoup de réformes dont
celle des retraites est une sacrée je
dirais bonne surprise pour une majorité
des français qui étaient contre 1,7 il
voulait oui si vous voulez vous ne
pouvez pas annoncer des mesures qui sont
quand même des mesures tout à fait
exceptionnel dans la vie quotidienne des
français depuis presque 60 disent en
avoir plus de 70 ans et ne pas donner un
moment donné un peu de mou qui
permettent tout simplement que les
français puissent accepter ces mesures
très contraignantes mais ce sont des
mesures temporaires de quinze jours donc
il fallait vraisemblablement tenir
compte de l'état de l'opinion publique
qui tue et elne opinion publique qui est
aujourd'hui pour le moins en tout cas
rétive à la politique d' emmanuel macron
pour faire passer ses mesures
contraignantes dans un contexte
d'urgence que l'on connaît sans compter
les mesures économiques qui l'a annoncée
de soutien à l'économie qui sont pour le
coup elle dans la droite ligne de déjà
ce qu'il avait annoncé lors de son
intervention jeudi
mais encore une fois je crois que on est
dans une communication à deux étages il
faut être extrêmement prudent sur les
commentaires qu'on est en train de faire
et des observations que l'on peut
émettre sur son intervention parce que
ce qui va être important dans les heures
qui viennent ce sont les modalités
d'application des mesures qui sont
annoncées par le président de la
république et on voit quand même que
depuis maintenant je dis il ya une
répartition des rôles entre d'un côté le
président de la république donne le cap
et puis un premier ministre qui vient
ensuite dans un second temps très vives
et les mesures qui ont été annoncées par
le président de la république alors ya
quand même une mesure elle qui est
certaine ça ne vous a évidemment pas
échappé second tour des municipales
reporter quel est l'avis du communicant
sur cette question alors que s'est tenu
le premier tour dimanche dernier
alors outre le problème juridique que ça
va inévitablement posée je crois que
finalement le président de la république
a réussi à obtenir le consensus des
forces politiques qui n'avaient pas pu
obtenir lors de son intervention jeudi
et d'ailleurs je dis on l'avait noté
qu'il s'était essentiellement appuyée
sur l'avis des scientifiques pour
justifier
sa décision de maintenir le premier tour
des élections municipales
on savait très bien que finalement ce
n'était pas une question scientifique
qui se posaient pour que ce premier tour
soient tenues c'était tout simplement
qu'il n'avait pas réussi à obtenir un
compromis autour des principales forces
politiques qui manifestement était
opposé dans la séquence que nous
traversions voilà un au tour des
élections municipales
merci arnaud benedetti en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur rt france et
on l'a appris il ya quelques minutes en
même temps que le discours du président
nouvelle progression en france 2002 sont
ni cas est lié au corona virus et 21
décès en 24 heures de plus portant le
total à 148 morts et 6633 car
précisément depuis le début de
l'épidémie du coronavirus chiffre
évidemment donnée par la santé publique
france la france qui est donc
officiellement passé au stade 3 depuis
ce samedi depuis aujourd'hui tous les
établissements scolaires sont fermés les
précisions de lucas tueur scène insolite
ce matin dans les rues de la capitale
les parisiens font la queue devant les
supermarchés un mètre de distance entre
chaque personne ce sont les
recommandations sanitaires en vigueur
on a des rumeurs sur des chiffres cinq
semaines six semaines fin voilà c'est
comme ça
tout se passe tout seul chez soi a pas
chantage chez soi sauf pour faire
quelques courses de tous et ça va être
compliqué mais bon après je préfère ça
que d'avoir une épidémie qui se répand
et d'avoir des dizaines voire des
centaines de millions de morts que c'est
normal de faire ça mais c'est de rester
sereins on a deux enfants à la maison
section cp ont fait l'école à la maison
le télétravail les cours sont c'était
déjà un petit peu organisés mais
n'anticipait plus pouvoir sortir comme
un petit moment on s'adapte on n'achète
pas un masque on est quand même un petit
peu prévenant pour essayer d'avoir
quelques réserves parce qu'on ne sait
pas qu'est ce qu'il en est donc on
essaye d'avoir ce qu'il faut un nouveau
rythme et un nouveau visage pour les
centres urbains
la mairie de paris annonce lundi la
fermeture des parcs et des jardins et la
mise en place du stationnement
résidentiel gratuit de son côté la ratp
déclare réduire son trafic dès ce mardi
face à une épidémie qualifié de très
inquiétantes par le directeur de la
santé jérôme salomon le nombre de cas
double désormais tous les trois jours
je voudrais surtout que nos concitoyens
se rendent compte qu'il y a des
personnes qui sont malades en
réanimation et dont le pronostic vital
est engagé
et ces personnes se chiffrent en
centaines des centaines de personnes en
réanimation
le risque dans les jours à venir est une
saturation des services hospitaliers
alors pour gérard kernec médecin
urgentiste le respect des consignes de
sécurité et capitale prenant cette
hypothèse base de 15 millions 1 % qui
nécessite de la réanimation sur 15
millions ça fait cent cinquante mille
personnes qui ont besoin de réanimation
or nos capacités sont de 15000 places en
réanimation ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on pouvait prendre un dixième
des patients en charge d'où la stratégie
du gouvernement depuis le début de cette
crise de freiner de ralentir d'aplatir
cette vague qui risque de submerger pour
que cette vague puisse passer plusieurs
semaines sur plusieurs mois
éventuellement pour pouvoir lisser les
choses et que ces 150 mille malades si
on part sur 7 y posa hypothèse là
puissent avoir tous une place en
réanimation si vous les prenez tous la
même pour semaine vous n'aurez pas la
place si vous les prenez sur une dizaine
de semaines
on peut espérer pouvoir absorber ce flux
de patients écoles fermées comme les
tribunaux les restaurants les cafés et
les commerces n'ont essentiel face à une
france déjà bien ralenti certains
craignent un confinement total en
particulier dans les grandes métropoles
où la population est dense
selon eux la meilleure option reste le
départ jouer en kit c'est un vent pareil
oui parce que
on prend le moins de risque possible
pour aller loin de nos parents parce que
safe pour travailler semaine dans une
ambiance un peu sérieuse pour éviter
paris parce que les hôpitaux vont être
surchargé moi je veux rentrer chez moi
puis je vais respecter jouer les
morceaux les chinois je marcherai quoi
les trains roulent encore mais ils
seront sans doute moins nombreux dans
les prochains jours le gouvernement a
décidé dimanche de réduire drastiquement
les transports avec un trafic
ferroviaire divisé par deux et seulement
quelques vols internationaux
ensuite de notre émission spéciale
consacrée donc à la crise du coronavirus
avec l'italie également le pays d'europe
qui paye le plus lourd tribut à la
pandémie qui a dépassé la barre des 2000
morts avec 349 décès dans les dernières
24 heures en plus le gouvernement
italien a adopté aujourd'hui un décret
contenant des mesures d'un montant
d'environ 25 milliards d'euros il s'agit
notamment de soutenir les familles et
les entreprises touchés à la pandémie
ces mesures supplémentaires doivent être
adoptées en avril écouter le premier
ministre italien giuseppe compter l'eau
sadequee l'émission et disputes l'état
et présentera des mesures de relance et
mettre au pas les instituts qui se dit
conscient des problèmes crête de la
présence de l'état
nous proposerons une règle ou le reflex
dont le domaine économique nous avons
été les premiers à m
ils présentent des fiches de les
familles mademoiselle de 350 unis il
s'agit d'une mesure inapplicable deros
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis rome avec paula moss cardinaux au
journaliste reporter pour la chaîne de
télévision italienne
l'a7 c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir un bon soir paula
mosca dino merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france
le bilan qui continue un évidemment
augmenter en italie quelle est la
situation sur place
les bons jours plus tôt pour soir
j'étais petit ma les derniers chiffres n
est qu une couverture nationale de
l'association
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous avons 23 militaires
affirmé de 349 morts c'est à dire qu'en
une journée
nous avons eu 3 149 morts ce commentaire
[Musique]
mais on observe une tendance et
défendant très légère nous sommes à une
phase très difficile j'ai entendu le
discours de riches m'a pris au pays et
j'apprécie le fait de décider de
d'adopter des mesures strictes comme en
italie
à la clé ce week-end me john is deeply
qu'aux situations ça frisait difficile
cette guerre véritable aide maintenant à
bien utiliser le nom ne pourra cette
année les liens que si tous les pays
européens d'adapter les mesures strictes
contre cet ennemi invisible en live au
stabilo on n'a pas encore évidemment
l'explication de texte dans les détails
du gouvernement qui va s'atteler à le
faire dès demain mais pour le moment
selon notre compréhension et belle macro
et a écarté un confinement total à
l'italienne parce qu'il me semble que
vous vous ne pouvez vraiment pas sortir
de chez vous sous peine d'amendé
il appelle à limiter les déplacements il
proscrit les déplacements dans les
quinze jours seulement mais les français
ne semblent pas être en confinement
total chez eux c'est peut-être une
petite nuance quand même importante non
il est important pourtant de rester chez
soi des lecteurs et des scientifiques
ont été très clairs là-dessus rester à
la maison et le seul moyen pour à
ralentir pu éviter la propagation du
virus à mais je fais la seule wheels
sûrs que nous ayons oui c'est inouï oui
weekly nous restons chez nous devons pas
quitter le domicile sans une implication
valide sur s'agissait d'aller travailler
acheter de la nourriture de médicaments
si notre pays est complètement
verrouillé
nous ne connaissons pas le résultat de
cette mesure
oui oui non mehdi nous savons que c'est
le seul moyen d'influencer la situation
de lutter contre ce virus
[Musique]
en italie la situation est très
préoccupante notamment dans le nord car
celui-là qui est l'épicentre de la fin
des niches au sud du pays few
il y a des cas il y avait très peu de
cas en tout cas jusqu'à ce que beaucoup
de personnes plus de cinquante mille
personnes se déplacent du nord vers le
sud pour retrouver la famille semaines
après cette grande transhumance ce
déplacement massif
le nombre des cas a commencé à augmenter
cela montre bien l'importance de ce
confinement
il faut suivre les règles du
gouvernement
ça monte à 5 pour l'accepter car c'est
une mesure baby sitting in 18 merci par
la pomme pardonnez moi de vous de vous
couper de la sorte il ya un nid un
invité espagnol également qui attend
depuis un petit moment on va devoir le
prendre aussi en direct merci en tout
cas pas aulas moss cardinaux d'avoir été
avec nous en direct on a bien compris en
tout cas la situation en italie merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france merci
et dans ce contexte l'espagne annonce
donc la fermeture de son côté de ses
frontières terrestres afin de contenir
l'expansion du coronavirus selon le
ministre de l'intérieur le pays recense
près de 1500 nouveaux cas en 24 heures
et le confinement de 15 jours risque de
durer françois xavier lambert
des rames de métro quasiment déserté la
capitale espagnole prend des allures de
ville fantôme alors que l'espagne et
placées en état d' alerte dans les rues
les forces de l'ordre se déploient en
nombre pour faire appliquer les mesures
de confinement qui sont entrées en
vigueur à minuit pour 15 jours des
militaires ont été déployés dans 14
villes pour aider au nettoyage et faire
respecter les restrictions de
circulation
nous devons être conscients que cela ne
doit pas nous faire paniquer ni nous
faire prendre des mesures extrêmes ce
qu'on doit faire c'est être responsable
et nos responsabilités commence par
prendre des mesures d'hygiène suffisante
et les mesures de distanciation sociale
demande et nous ne devrons pas nous
inquiéter au delà de ça pourtant
certains refusent encore de se plier aux
injonctions des autorités
dans la station balnéaire de benidorm la
police locale a dû intervenir face à des
touristes attablé en terrasse des
consignes non respectées également dans
la gare d'atocha à madrid où des
centaines de passagers se sont pressés
ce matin les mesures drastiques met
aussi les entreprises à l'arrêt faute de
pièces détachées les constructeurs
automobiles renault seat nissan et ps en
suspendu leurs usines espagnoles
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer la
fermeture des frontières terrestres et
pour en parler nous sommes avec nicolas
klain spécialiste de l'espagne
contemporaine
bonsoir nicolas klain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france l'espagne
qui a donc annoncé fermer ses frontières
ce soir minuit une bonne chose selon
vous c'était sans doute inévitable de
toute façon ça faisait plusieurs jours
que cette idée s'impose et lentement
dans les esprits donc les frontières
terrestres de toute façon c'est le
minimum puisque pour le moment il n'y a
pas encore de décision sur
l'aéroportuaire et le maritime
mais ça ça semblait inévitable ce fait
ces manifestants pourquoi cette une
décision selon vont qui intervient
maintenant ce que ce n'est pas tardif
est le gouvernement aurait peut-être pu
prendre cette décision avant de toute
façon le gouvernement espagnol de pedro
sanchez a réagi très tardivement même
bien avant cette annonce de la fermeture
des frontières terrestres
il y a encore un peu plus d'une semaine
le dimanche 8 mars
il incitait les gens à venir manifester
dans les rues pour la journée mondiale
des droits des femmes alors qu' il y
avait des dd fait très fort est
fortement déconseillé à la fois par
l'union européenne et par les autorités
scientifiques espagnols que beaucoup de
partis de personnalités demandé que ces
manifestations sur des programmes et est
globalement le gouvernement pedro
sanchez a malheureusement est très très
tardive dans ses réponses alors depuis
quelques jours on voit un emballement et
une radicalisation des mesures qui sont
prises mais elles n'arrivent globalement
tard ce qui explique aussi la gravité de
la situation dans le pays
alors effectivement deuxième pays
d'europe le plus touché les hôpitaux
sont ils saturent et on précise qu'il
est à mille cas supplémentaires en 24
heures ça fait plus de 8000 car en
espagne telle est la situation des
hôpitaux en espagne alors c'est très
variable selon les communautés autonomes
c'est la communauté de madrid qui est la
plus touchée mais ce n'est pas tellement
étonnant puisque c'est là la principale
porte d'entrée du pays c'est le coeur
économique et politique du pays
donc certains hôpitaux de la communauté
de madrid effectivement sont dans une
situation tendue
je pense notamment aux hôpitaux la
banlieue est comme un torero de ardoz
par exemple où se sont déclarés les
premières grandes vagues
de contagion progressivement on va voir
jusqu'à mercredi encore de nouveaux
afflux dans les hôpitaux la la
communauté de madrid est peut-être une
des rares régions avoir réagi très
rapidement
justement repart en comparaison du
gouvernement national au d'autres
régions et elle essaie aujourd'hui de
tout faire pour habiliter de nouveaux
espaces de soin pour créer de nouveaux
lits dans les unités de soins intensifs
tout ça effectivement il est tendu et
malheureusement je pense que les
hôpitaux de la région et plus largement
les hôpitaux espagnols ne sont pas
sortis d'affaires alors 46 millions
d'habitants n'ont plus le droit de
sortir de chez eux que pour des raisons
impératives comme aller travailler se
rendre à la pharmacie se faire soigner
ou acheter à manger un petit peu sans
doute ce qui va se passer en france on
attend l'explication de texte d'edouard
philippe qu'on va d'ailleurs suivre dans
quelques minutes un premier ministre qui
doit s'exprimer à 21h à ce que les les
espagnols respecte ses consignes des
toasts des autorités globalement oui
bien sûr qu'il y ait toujours des
exceptions mais globalement oui ils les
respectent
on a eu un premier bilan des amendes et
des arrestations aujourd'hui dans les
principales villes à l'encontre dès
personnes ne les a pas respectées et que
ce soit à madrid ou barcelone par
exemple ça concerne une petite centaine
ou au pire 200 individus donc c'est
marginal 1 sur des des agglomérations
qui par exemple pour madrid fait six
millions d'habitants aujourd'hui quel
est l'état d'esprit des espagnols face à
cette crise sans précédent avec emmanuel
macron appelé les français à rester unis
à ne pas céder à la panique on a vu que
nous en france quelques accès de panique
1 ces dernières heures des gens qui
fuient et notamment la capitale pour
aller se réfugier à la campagne de peur
d'un confinement total quel est l'état
d'esprit en espagne alors l'état
d'esprit je pense qu'il est globalement
combatifs les gens confiance non pas
tellement dans leurs responsables
politiques qui ont plu sur cette crise
ne l'auront globalement non pouvait pas
donner de raison d'avoir confiance en
eux mais ils ont confiance dans le
système de santé je rappelle toujours
malgré cette crise l'espagne un des
meilleurs systèmes de santé au monde un
qui est régulièrement classé dans les
meilleurs au monde par tout de suite
séries de fondations et organismes
qu'ils ont confiance dans leur système
de santé
même s'ils savent que ça va être très
difficile ils ont confiance dans les
forces de l'ordre dans l'armée
maintenant effectivement il ya eu des
débordements des gens qui sont
précipités dans les supermarchés comme
en france et aussi des madrilènes qui
sont partis la semaine dernière en
province non pas par peur d'un
confinement mais simplement parce que
ils devaient aller travailler ou qu'il
n'avait plus rien à faire dans la
capitale il faut savoir que madrid avec
beaucoup de gens qui sont originaires
d'autres régions de l'espagne mais
globalement on sent les gens respectueux
aujourd'hui du confinement et combatif
je pense tous fois et ça beaucoup
d'espagnols de 10 sur les réseaux
sociaux qu une fois que la crise sera
réglé on l'espère le plus vite possible
des responsabilités politiques seront
demandés ça c'est très clair
merci beaucoup à nicolas klinger était
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
évoquer la situation de l'espagne
l'espagne qui ferme ses frontières ce
soir à minuit deuxième pays d'europe le
plus touché avec mille cas
supplémentaires en 24 heures et plus de
8000 cas au total il est 21h soyez les
bienvenus
si vous nous rejoignez en direct sur rt
france pour cette deuxième heure
émission entièrement consacrée à la
crise du coronavirus voici les titres
consacrés à cette crise
nous sommes en guerre en guerre
sanitaire l'ennemi est là invisible
emmanuel macron s'est donc adressé à 20h
aux français sur cette crise sanitaire
plus de 20 minutes d'allocution le
président exhortent la population des
sacrifices et à limiter ses déplacements
dès demain midi
ce pour une durée de 15 jours parmi les
autres mesures annoncées
toutes les réformes en cours suspendus
dont celle des retraites et le report du
second tour des élections municipales
on dénombre aujourd'hui 6633 cas et 148
morts dans le pays
pour les détails et les explications de
texte pour de ces mesures d' emmanuel
macron va écouter dans quelques instants
en direct edouard philippe sur notre
chaîne et les frontières à l'entrée de
l'union européenne et de schengen seront
fermées dès mardi midi comme l'a précisé
le président de la république
le g7 qui s'est tenue en sommet
extraordinaire par visioconférence
aujourd'hui évoque une tragédie humaine
et plaide pour une coordination sur la
gestion des frontières alors que
l'espagne annonce fermé les siennes le
bison d'épidémie dépasse les 7000
personnes dans le monde
2158 à rien en italie
[Musique]
et les membres du g7 qui se sont dits
déterminés à faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour restaurer la croissance
mondiale alors qu'une fois de plus les
bourses mondiales sont en chute libre
fermeture évidemment en très forte
baisse à francfort paris et londres
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il ya quelques minutes une heure
précisément emmanuel macron appelé donc
la raison et la responsabilité de chaque
français le président a annoncé
plusieurs mesures pour lutter contre le
coronavirus est notamment des
déplacements fortement réduit écouter le
président de la république j'ai décidé
de renforcer encore les mesures pour
réduire nos déplacements et nos contacts
au strict nécessaire dès demain midi et
pour quinze jours au moins nos
déplacements seront très fortement
réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promener retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
il s'agit de limiter au maximum ses
contacts au delà du foyer partout sur le
territoire français en métropole comme
outre-mer seules doivent demeurer les
trajets nécessaire nécessaire pour aller
faire ses courses avec de la discipline
et en mettant les distance d'au moins un
mètre en ne serrant pas la main en
embrassant pas les trajets nécessaire
pour se soigner
évidemment les trajets nécessaire pour
aller travailler quand le travail à
distance n'est pas possible et les
trajets nécessaires pour faire un peu
d'activité physique mais sans retrouver
là encore des amis ou des proches et
celle phare je vous trouvez devant
l'elysée que faut-il dû retenir retenir
du discours d' emmanuel macron
donc ça me hangar sanitaire 1 contre le
corona virus a martelé le chef de l'état
pendant son allocution une prise d'une
patte de parole d'une vingtaine de
minutes pendant laquelle le chef de
l'état a annoncé une série
mesures pour lutter contre le coc vide
et 19 je vous demande des sacrifices
pour ralentir l'épidémie a déclaré
emmanuel macron il a tout d'abord salué
les premières
mise en place jeudi dernier le chef de
l'état qui a déploré que certains
français n'avait pas respecté les gestes
barrières et les consignes s sanitaire
dès demain midi des consignes plus
strictes seront donc mises en place les
réunions familiales
réunion amicale tout cela ne sera plus
possible les déplacements seront aussi
fortement réduit et sept au gouvernement
que revient la tâche dont la soirée de
préciser l'application modalités
d'application de ces mesures dès mardi
les frontières de l'union européenne et
de l'espace schengen seront fermés une
décision commune entre européens a
précisé le chef de l'état je vous
propose de l'écouter
nous sommes en guerre aussi comme je
voulais dit jeudi pour nous protéger et
contenir la dissémination du virus mais
aussi préserver le système de soins nous
avons pris ce matin entre européens
une décision commune dès demain midi les
frontières à l'entrée de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen
seront fermés concrètement tous les
voyages entre les pays non européens et
l'union européenne seront suspendues
pendant 30 jours
les françaises et les français qui sont
actuellement à l'étranger et souhaite
rentrer pourront bien entendu rejoindre
leur pays enfin emmanuel macron a
précisé à que toutes les réformes en
cours sont suspendues
même sort pour le second tour des
élections municipales qui est donc
reporté
merci estelle farges en direct donc de
l'elysée merci à vous et restez avec
nous dans quelques instants on va donc
écouté l'allocution non pas d'edouard
philippe may 2 christophe castaner pour
les détails des mesures annoncées par
emmanuel macron en attendant on va les
retrouver
elodie schmitt elodie schmitt merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
membre du bureau national du collectif
inter bloc infirmières spécialiste de
chirurgie cardiaque à l'hôpital henri
mondor de créteil
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france tout d'abord une première
réaction à ce discours d' emmanuel
macron c'est est ce que vous attendiez
dont fars oui donc oui on attend des
femmes et je pense que le mesure sont
arrivés un peu tard après ben el hout
arrivés tous mieux mais voilà on a je
pense qu'on a perdu quand même du temps
sur la gestion de la crise déplacement
pour 15 jours proscrit limiter les
contacts
on est quand même loin de du confinement
total annoncé par tout le monde parce
que d'après vous le président a changé
d'avis il a peut-être hésiter c'est une
bonne chose en tout cas de ne pas être
allé dans une contrainte aussi extrêmes
je pense qu'il faut vraiment une
contrainte et que quand même parce que
là le virus se propage vraiment très
rapidement la situation est dramatique
même catastrophique d'un grand est et
puis en ile de france également
donc je ne fais pas pourquoi il a fait
ça peut-être par souci économique a un
petit peu peut-être que les choses
durent fuir ou encore demain ou après
demain puisque ça change régulièrement
mais bon là je sais pas qui fait se fera
suffisant vu le l'état des actuels des
choix justement vous parlez d'une
situation catastrophique le grand test
plusieurs témoignages ont filtré en ce
sens effectivement d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron annoncé un hôpital de campagne
des armes est installé en alsace
quel est notre réaction à cette annonce
matin montre bien la gravité de la
situation et je pense qu'on arrivera à
la même chose en ile-de-france et puis
ailleurs enfin en fait on n'a pas la
capacité d'accueillir tous les patients
au sein de les hôpitaux j'ai vu un
forfait qui est d'ouvrir des lits
d'hôpitaux à côté d'autres campagnes les
réanimations son plein on n'a pas assez
de matériel on n'a pas de masque je vous
parle même pas des masques ffp2 on n'a
pas assez de masques chirurgicaux
c'est une catastrophe sanitaire alors
apparemment sur les masques justement
emmanuel macron annoncé un stock qui
sera possible de chercher notamment dans
l'est dans les pharmacies est ce que
c'est de nature à vous rassurer
non non non parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya un puck qui fera un survivant
et je ne comprends même pas pourquoi il
n'est pas en place dès maintenant pour
qu'on n'a pas accès au mac dès
maintenant on est en contact et
aujourd'hui maintenant ce n'est pas
demain c'est après demain c'est tout
donc non je comprends pas et ça ça me
rassure pas plus que ça parce que les
pharmacies
voilà à quoi je pense qu'elles vont mal
on sait depuis quelques matchs à
certaines personnes mais la grosse part
indiqué qu'il nous faut et des mâts et
le 10 mai nous parliez du de situation
catastrophique en alsace on disait qu'on
effectivement le savez puisque plusieurs
témoignages on filtre est en ce sens
vous me parliez aussi de l'île de france
est ce qu'on se dirige vers une
situation en ile de france
à l'instar de l'alsace où on en est
quand même pas là non choix quant au
lycée enfin on se dirige tout à fait
puisque de toute façon entre l'italie et
la france
les choses se sont dirigés de la même
manière et là bas ça va continue son
avancée et ile de france en terme de
places en réanimation
déjà les gens sont déjà en réanimation
là dès aujourd'hui il ya eu beaucoup de
ce qui t'a alisation des gens jeunes des
gens un jeune il est des gens de 30 ans
37,1 des femmes de 37 ans donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une situation
gravissime mais c'est pas forcément des
gens qui ont qui sont sous soudanais
c'est à dire des anti-inflammatoires ou
des gens qui ont des antécédents
quelconque j'ai des gens qui n'ont aucun
antécédent donc il ya des personnes va
j'étais vraiment et qui sont en
réanimation il ya aussi des personnes
jeunes donc c'est très important ce que
vous vous dînerez indiqué parce que
c'est vrai qu'au début on parlait
évidemment de personnes âgées ou de
personnes près fréquentes pardon
présentant des facteurs de comorbidité
c'est à dire des facteurs aggravants là
vous nous dites clairement il ya
énormément fin il ya beaucoup de profils
de jeunes qui nous présente pas d
antécédents ou qui n'ont pas pris je
décrypte est des ebooks prochaine parce
que c'était ça qui était un petit peu
pointé du doigt ces derniers jours ne
s'est pas le cas en tout cas ça veut
dire que manon hily à toutes sortes fuis
pas je lis pas qu'il y en a beaucoup
mais il y en a arrive et il faut il faut
le lire il faut voir les choses en face
il n'ya pas seulement que des personnes
âgées de 92 ans avec énormément de
l'amplifier en fait pareil à des gens
qui sont jeunes
enfin vous qu'un amplifiée en avoir
enquêté dans en commun bilité vous
l'expliquez comment est-ce que c'est une
évolution de ces derniers jouent tout
simplement au début soit on n'avait pas
d'information soit peut-être qu'elle ne
filtrait pas par manque de communication
oui je pense qu'il ya eu quand même un
gros manque de communication à tous les
niveaux parce que cesse cette situation
en fait on la connaît depuis le mois de
décembre en chine le premier médecin qui
a alerté la qui est des faits b il était
il était jeune donc je pense que c'est
un manque de communication je ne sais
pas pourquoi je pense que c'est pas
peut-être pour essayer de ne pas alerter
de pas sombrer dans une situation
économique
intenable mais bon là on est on est
devant le mur est on ne peut plus faire
autrement donc il faut jours maintenant
dire la vérité aux gens parce que aussi
à moi ce que je trouve un peu la musique
et le fait de faire culpabiliser les
gens sur des éventuels parti qu'ils
auraient créé hier ou avant-hier mais il
faut peut-être aussi se poser la
question de la communication est ce
qu'elle a été bonne
est ce qu'on a vraiment montré la
gravité de la chose avant voilà fort
pouvoir parce que je pense que la
communication n'a pas été vraiment
qu'elle aurait dû être dès le départ
merci beaucoup en tout cas elodie
schmitt pour votre témoignage d'un
membre du bureau national du collectif
inter bloc infirmières spécialiste de
chirurgie cardiaque à l'hôpital mondor à
créteil merci à vous et autres réactions
à présent autre témoignage nous sommes
en direct avec françois chauvancy
général de brigade on dirait que sur rt
france bonsoir françois chauvancy merci
d'être avec nous est ce que vous en tant
que général de l'armée est ce qu'on vous
a mobilisé ce qu'on a fait appel à vous
les armées ont été mobilisés ce soir le
président macro comme chef des armées
l'a bien rappelé il a fait appel
notamment au service de santé des armées
qui sont capables de projeter sûreté
internationales notamment des hôpitaux
militaires de campagne donc je crois que
les armées sont totalement investis dans
ce besoin de protéger la population
et effectivement les armées sont
concernés dès aujourd'hui de cette
mesure de protection
quel va être votre rôle le rôle des
armées le premier rôle et sanitaires
nous avons un service de santé qui fait
plus de quinze mille personnes qui a
huit hôpitaux militaires tôt que des
capacités de réanimation ce dont on
parle beaucoup depuis quelques jours on
nous avons des besoins au niveau
national c'est aussi le déploiement
notamment dans l'est de la france suite
à votre reportage il ya quelques
instants d'un hôpital militaire de
campagne c'est-à-dire des médecins
militaires avec des infirmiers
militaires qui vont être déployés pour
justement aider les hôpitaux civils et
je crois que ça fait tout à fait partie
de la mission sanitaire désarmé alors
emmanuel macron n'a pas annoncé le
confinement total semble-t-il à l'instar
de de l'italie mais
l'interdiction des déplacements pour 15
jours sauf si on doit travailler où
aller se faire soigner est ce que dans
ce cas l'armée un rôle ça veut dire que
il va y avoir une surveillance des
français non je ne crois pas qu'il faut
comprendre cela comme cela de toute
façon les armées français sur le
territoire national sont soumis à des
règles sont soumis aussi à l'autorité
civile en l'occurrence en fonction des
départements les préfets peuvent
demander la participation des armées
pour assurer une certaine forme de
contrôle dans le respect de la loi
nous avons déjà l'opération sentinelle
qui est toujours présente et qui est
toujours déployés sur le terrain
et d'ailleurs le président de la
république pour l'instant ni le premier
ministre n'ont évoqué des suppléments de
force ce cadre national pour exercer des
missions de contrôle ou de surveillance
aujourd'hui le président a également
annoncé que la frontière un des pays de
l'union européenne seront fermés pour 30
jours sauf pour les français qui
souhaitent revenir de de l'étranger
l'armée aura un rôle à jouer également
sur les contrôles de frontières
la logique voudrait que ce soit une
possibilité qui n'a pas été évoqué tout
dépend aujourd'hui finalement des
effectifs disponibles au service des
douanes de la police tout le monde peut
être concerné par la maladie du coran
navires us aujourd'hui donc je pense que
les armées sont dans leur tradition en
force de troisième catégorie capable
d'être réquisitionnés pour assurer des
missions sur le territoire national en
cas de besoin 1
et donc pour suppléer des forces qui
seraient aujourd'hui comme la police en
situation de déficit d'effectif merci
beaucoup françois chauvancy général de
brigade d'avoir été avec mon direct sur
rt france est la france qui est donc
officiellement passé au stade 3 ce
samedi depuis aujourd'hui tous les
établissements scolaires sont fermés les
précisions de lucas tueur
scène insolite ce matin dans les rues de
la capitale les parisiens font la queue
devant les supermarchés un mètre de
distance entre chaque personne ce sont
les recommandations sanitaires en
vigueur
on a des rumeurs sur des chiffres cinq
semaines six semaines enfin voila j'ai
comme ça tout se fera tout seul chez soi
a pas sur ta chez soi si on pour faire
quelques courses de tous et ça va être
compliqué mais bon après je préfère ça
que d'avoir une épidémie qui se répand
et d'avoir des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliers de morts que c'est
normal de faire ça c'est le rester
serein on a deux enfants à la maison qui
sont petites sections cp donc on fait
l'école à la maison du télétravail les
cours sont c'était déjà un petit peu
organisés mais n'anticipe plus pouvoir
sortir comme un petit moment
on s'adapte on n'achète pas un masque
quand on est quand même un petit peu
prévenant pour essayer d'avoir quelques
réserves parce qu'on ne sait pas qu'est
ce qu'il en est donc on essaye d'avoir
ce qu'il faut un nouveau rythme et un
nouveau visage pour les centres urbains
la mairie de paris annonce lundi la
fermeture des parcs et des jardins et la
mise en place du stationnement
résidentiel gratuit de son côté la ratp
déclare réduire son trafic dès ce mardi
face à une épidémie qualifié de très
inquiétantes par le directeur de la
santé jérôme salomon le nombre de cas
double désormais tous les trois jours
je voudrais surtout que nos concitoyens
se rendent compte qu'il y a des
personnes qui sont malades en
réanimation et dont le pronostic vital
est engagé
et ces personnes se chiffrent en
centaines des centaines de personnes en
réanimation
le risque dans les jours à venir est une
saturation des services hospitaliers
alors pour gérard kernec médecin
urgentiste le respect des consignes de
sécurité et capitale prenant cette
hypothèse base de 15 millions 1 % qui
nécessite de la réanimation sur 15
millions ça fait cent cinquante mille
personnes qui ont besoin de réanimation
or le capacités sont de 15000 places en
réanimation ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on pouvait prendre un dixième
des patients en charge d'où la stratégie
du gouvernement depuis le début de cette
crise de freiner de ralentir d'aplatir
cette vague qui risque de submerger pour
que cette vague puisse passer plusieurs
semaines sur plusieurs mois
éventuellement pour pouvoir lisser les
choses et que ces 150 mille malades si
on part sur cette île aux arts hypothèse
là puissent avoir tous une place en
réanimation si vous les prenez tous la
même semaine vous n'aurez pas la place
si vous les prenez sur une dizaine de
semaines
on peut espérer pouvoir absorber ce flux
de patients écoles fermées comme les
tribunaux les restaurants les cafés et
les commerces n'ont essentiel face à une
france déjà bien ralenti certains
craignent un confinement total en
particulier dans les grandes métropoles
où la population est dense
selon eux la meilleure option reste le
départ oui en kit si avant paris ouais
parce que
on prend le moins de risque possible
pour aller loin de nos parents parce que
safe pour travailler se mettre dans une
ambiance un peu sérieuse pour éviter
paris parce que les hôpitaux on a très
surchargé
moi je veux rentrer chez moi puis je
vais respecter jouer le mausolée chinois
je marcherai les trains roulent encore
mais ils seront sans doute moins
nombreux dans les prochains jours le
gouvernement a décidé dimanche de
réduire drastiquement les transports
avec un trafic ferroviaire divisé par
deux et seulement quelques vols
internationaux et selon exavier
pommereau psychiatre la période est
certes préoccupante mais il ne faut pas
céder à la panique
l'anxiété par contagion elle évidemment
elles marchent comme nous les russes
c'est à dire que tout le monde se
comptaient mutuellement en voyant que
tout le monde fait des provisions en
entendant qu'il ya plus de papier
toilette etc et donc les gens se livrent
à ces à ses débauches en quelque sorte
de d'achat par angoisse par peur de
manquer pour et aussi je pense pour ce
pour se rassurer en se disant voilà on
va tenir le coup
on a cinq kilos de pâtes et 10 kg de riz
on va pouvoir tenir le siège est quelque
chose de très très fort et de très
violents on est dans une situation de
guerre - les patientes que j'ai depuis
ce matin au téléphone qui m'appelle sont
sont angoissés de en demandant mais
qu'est-ce qui va précéder qu'est ce qui
va se passer demain et bien entendu je
peux pas leur répondre sinon que qu'elle
reste chez elle qu'elle fasse attention
et que tout le monde va essayer de gérer
les choses calmement mais qu'il faut
garder son calme c'est vraiment
probablement l'injonction qu'il faut
absolument faire passer dans les médias
parce qu'à la panique ça résout jamais
rien et au contraire ça fait amplifier
encore le phénomène des conséquences
économiques à présent les bourses du
monde entier sont en chute libre malgré
les efforts des banques mondiales après
les pertes historiques de la semaine
dernière la bourse de new york poursuit
sa dégringolade son indice mbao jones
affiche une baisse de plus de 9% la
bourse de francfort elle plonge à 10% le
plus bas niveau depuis 2003
16 celle de paris s'enfonce et de 10 % à
la mi-séance aujourd'hui une situation
semblable à celle d'une guerre pour le
président de l'eurogroupe de son côté la
commission européenne les firmes de
grandes répercussions sur l'économie
sont à prévoir
la situation est très incertaine avec
l'évolution de la pandémie et ses
ramifications économique
mais comme nous l'avons dit vendredi
lorsque nous avons publié notre
communication sur la réponse coordonnée
aux mepi limites du court noué un virus
la répercussion sera négative c'est
certain récession en 2020 c'est envisagé
à ce stade si nous n'avons pas encore
revu nos prévisions nous savons
seulement préparer des scénarii ce sont
des scénarii qui sont élaborées par le
personnel de la commission la commission
estime accuseront une contraction de
l'économie de l'ue mais des prévisions
plus précises seront présentés plus tard
début mai et pour parler de cet aspect
économique nous sommes avec olivier
delamarche économise bonsoir olivier
delamarche merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france les bourses qui
ont une fois de plus plongé aujourd'hui
est ce que l'économiste que vous êtes
est inquiet oui je suis inquiet parce
que sinon je serais je serai
complètement fou si je l'étais pas on
est dans une situation qu'on n'a jamais
connu avec des pays qui sont à l'arrêt
totalement
même en temps de guerre c'est où on est
pas on n'est pas à ce point là donc oui
il ya de quoi être inquiet et quand je
vois quelqu'un qui nous dit on n'a pas
encore bien abaisser nos prévisions et
on sait pas encore très bien si on être
en récession en 2020 je peux lui annoncé
on sera en récession en 2020 donc
et une récession une récession normale
ça vaut 30 40 % sur un marché financier
sur un indice actions et là comme c'est
une récession extraordinaire qu'on va
avoir une récession mondiale
tous les pays vont l'être en même temps
vous pouvez tabler sur quelque chose qui
sera plutôt compris autour de 60%
voilà donc le chemin est en partie fait
mais n'est pas fini et puis on a vu ce
qu'on attendait 1 1 dans des émissions
précédentes
je vous l'avais dit on a les banques
centrales qui utilisent le seul moyen
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
qui est le quantitative easing donc
elles vont déverser des centaines de
milliards sur nos têtes et exactement
comme en 2008-2009 et bien qu'est ce qui
s'est passé vous avez gonfler la bulle
sur les actions et sur les actifs
financiers risée et vous n'avez
absolument pas relancer les économies
réelles
donc on le sait on sait que ça n'a aucun
impact sur l'économie réelle
on sait que ça a un impact sur les
bourses c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il veut
le faire ils veulent retenir le les
marchés pour l'instant on peut pas dire
que ça a été très efficace parce que je
pense que le marché on veut encore plus
il s'est pas satisfait des 800 milliards
qu'a annoncé la fed
donc il est en train de baisser là on
est plutôt à 13 % de baisse
il est en train de baisser pourquoi
parce qu'il réclame plus d'argent sans
vraie marge de manoeuvre selon vous ils
ont pas de marge de manoeuvre puisque
les taux d'intérêt sont déjà à zéro
donc ça c'était un levier qu'ils avaient
avant et qu'ils n'ont plus aujourd'hui
et
le seul la seule marge de manoeuvre
qu'ils essaient de ces l'impression
monétaire sans limite
donc ils vont l'utiliser on l'a vu ils
ont commencé il ya eu des annonces
et puis mes mais c'est juste une
histoire de quantité et maintenant
qu'est ce qui va se passer
ils ne peuvent plus reculer c'est à dire
que s'il a fait si la fed si la bce
si la bo j arrête de deux de leurs
achats sur les marchés
eh bien les marchés ce que continuons à
se casser la figure
mais je vous dis on est encore on est
encore quelques 20 à 20 % de trop sur
les sur les marchés le japon n'a rien à
faire sur sur les niveaux actuels le
japon il doit être autour de de dix
mille onze mille sur sur le nikkei
pourquoi parce qu'ils vont avoir une
récession monstrueuse je vous rappelle
que le dernier trimestre japonais était
à -6 3% en annualisé alors que le le
quoran au virus n'était pas là au
dernier trimestre heineken que en 2020
donc il faut pas s'imaginer qui aura pas
de récession au japon
pareil on sait que la france amie
douze ans je parle sur votre contrôle
pour se remettre de la dernière
récession
quels sont vos pronostics pour celle ci
qui semble peut-être encore plus
importante
elle est beaucoup plus importante et
puis c'est surtout qu'on ne s'en est pas
remis la de la récession c'est à dire
que c'est bien là le problème c'est que
normalement dans un cycle normal vous
refaites du gras vous avez des
rémunérations qui qui augmente vous avez
un chômage qui diminue franchement on
est on est au plein emploi dans les
anciens cycle c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et donc vous partiez finalement de
très haut avec des croissances fortes et
cetera
et puis vous aviez une récession mais
l'un vous n'avez pas fait de gras les
gens n'ont pas fait de gras c'est bien
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il ya des gilet
jaune dans la rue depuis un an et demi
donc il n'ya pas de gras on n'a pas fait
baisser le chômage
donc on va partir de déjà d'un état qui
est très mauvais donc il faudra pas se
penser que vous allez comme j'entends
certains dire que vous allez avoir une
reprise en v c'est à dire une reprise
avec une pente ascendante quasi aussi
forte que la pente descendante pour
aller en session cet idiot parce que ça
va faire des dégâts qui seront des
dégâts irréparables alors vous n'êtes
pas là pardon vous coupez quelles vont
être les conséquences sur voilà les
citoyens français tout simplement les
économies en
dans les banques l'immobilier
chose qui intéresse un petit peu tout le
monde finalement les banques vous avez
vu qu en bourse elles sont au plus mal
et quand les banques sont au plus mal en
bourse c'est qu'a priori il se passe
quelque chose de pas très sympa dans
l'eure dans leur bilan donc oui on est
en risque majeur sur sur les banques
même si la banque centrale
un prime a tout ce qu'il faut pour
essayer de les tenir à bout de bras mais
mais en étant risques majeurs vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui sortent leur argent
des banques
enfin et on sait que ça va pas faim il
faut pas se font arrêter de se faire des
illusions en permanence on n'a jamais
réglé le problème qui a eu en 2008 on a
mis la poussière sous le tapis la
poussière est en train de ressortir et
et ça va être ça va être affreux et dès
aujourd'hui on a des banques centrales
qui sont on va dire mono'i des mots nos
mots nos actions qui ne savent qu'une
seule chose qu'ils ne savent faire
qu'une seule chose c'est imprimé
descendre à la cave et imprimés mais
descendre à la cave est imprimé ça n'a
jamais réglé aucun problème faire de la
dette pour régler un problème de dette
c'est idiot je pense que tout le monde
peut comprendre que quand yagg
il ya il ya un acteur qui est surendetté
le pour le sortir de là vous n'allez pas
lui remettre de la dette c'est pas c'est
complètement
on nous voit par exemple le lait le cas
de la grèce
en grèce c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est à
dire qu'on a continué joyeusement à les
endettés et il la grèce ne peut pas s'en
sortir maintenant la grèce elle est sous
perfusion en permanence et elle ne
pourra pas s'en sortir
et bien quand vous avez donc une
situation qui est déjà très dégradées
qui n'a pas été réglé
eh bien vous rajouter là-dessus un
événement comme le corps n'a vu virus
qui qui arrivent là dessus qui d'abord
déclenché les choses et ensuite les
aggrave et mais des pays à l'arrêt
l'italie est à l'arrêt depuis plus d'un
mois
nous on va être à l'arrêt à partir de
maintenant les tous les autres pays
européens c'est la même chose
on est à l'arrêt sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte y a plus rien qui sort des
chaînes de production
donc il faut pas s'imaginer que ça va
bien se passer que que monsieur macron
va compenser exactement toutes les
pertes de toutes les entreprises de tous
les de tous les acteurs économiques face
est ridicule
on sait bien qui pourra pas donc
arrêtons de rêver fin il nous enfume
comme à chaque fois on a l'impression de
quelqu'un qui sait absolument pas où il
va qui gère au jour le jour les choses
qui demandent à des experts qui en sont
pas qu'ils changent d'avis comme de
chemise
enfin on n'est pas dirigée a pas de
pilote dans l'avion et et tout le monde
continue à chanter à boire du champagne
en se disant ah bah ça va bien se passer
non ça va pas bien se passer si personne
ne sait piloter on va se crasher
merci olivier delabarre je sais pas si
je dois vous remercier pour toutes ces
mauvaises nouvelles mais je vous
remercie
quand même en tout cas pour votre
analyse en direct sur rt france et un
autre une autre réaction sur ses
conséquences économiques parce qu'elles
sont évidemment très importante vous
l'aurez compris dans cette crise du
corona virus philippe béchade rédacteur
en chef de la bourse au quotidien
bonsoir philippe béchade vous venez
certainement d'écouté l'analyse
d'olivier de ben ammar c'est ce que vous
partagez vous le même pessimisme en
partie parce que c'est vrai qu'on va
connaître des tons un peu difficile
maintenant je vais pas me lancer dans
des spéculations sur la durée de la
crise parce que je pense que c'est même
pas aujourd'hui la la question
fondamentale
nous venons de changer de monde donc à
un monde vient de s'éteindre
il ya un film qui s'appelait le jour où
l'appel à l'aide tarde et à ce jour eh
bien ce sera pour les livres d'histoire
pour livres d'économies qu'on écrira
dans le futur ce jour c'est le 16 mars
2020 donc voilà que le jour où la terre
s'arrêta et où le système qu'elle qu'on
l'a connue a cessé d'exister
alors maintenant nous rentrons enfin
pays la transition et à dire que tous
les cadres que nous connaissons depuis
l'avènement de l'euro les règles
d'orthodoxie budgétaire tous ça vole en
éclats tout ça n'existe plus quand on a
eu quelques petits quelques petites
galères que comme la crise grecque par
exemple on nous a dit n'avait pas
d'argent magie est que lorsqu à créteil
étaient survenus en 2010 on n'était pas
capable de sortir d'un milliard pour
éviter que le problème grec contamine
l'ensemble des économies européennes et
20 milliards on ne les avait pas à
l'époque là aujourd'hui on nous annonce
300 milliards pour soutenir les
entreprises françaises c'est absolument
nécessaires absolument indispensable est
justifié je vous rassure si dans quinze
jours on s'aperçoit qu'à 300 milliards
ne suffisent pas il y en a 300 de plus
il ya vraiment aujourd'hui il n'ya plus
haut puis les limites
ledent
la stratégie d'endiguement de
l'effondrement économique
alors on va évidemment sauver les
entreprises
on va essayer de sauver la consommation
et aux états unis les rumeurs que nous
entendons déjà c'est que on devrait
peut-être recouvre recourir très
rapidement son appel d'hélicoptères
monnaie c'est à dire que la fed versera
directement sur le compte de chaque
citoyen américain
une somme se chiffrant en milliers de
dollars plusieurs milliers de dollars en
fonction de la longueur de la crise
autrement dit on va faire en 2020 ce
qu'on n'a pas su ferrand en 2008
en 2008 on a redonné de l'argent aux
banques et pour relancer l'économie
il aurait fallu effectivement donné de
l'argent aussi aux victimes de la crise
c'est-à-dire les citoyens ceux qui
produisent la richesse
il s'est probablement ce qu'on va faire
cette fois ci alors je ne peux que m'en
féliciter sur le fond et le principe
par contre par contre il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à toutes les conséquences de
ce que je viens d'expliquer la silly
béchade justement à la fin qui va payer
alors ça c'est une excellente question
parce que depuis 2008
en ce qui concerne l'argent banque
centrale distribués aux états aux
banques
personne n'a jamais payé les dettes ne
sont jamais rembourser elles sont roulés
elles sont elles sont reportées
en europe on a une stratégie s'appelle
le tt zéro on en a créé 1 en 2015 arrivé
en 2018 les marchés pousser des cris de
douleur il avait besoin de plus de
l'utilité on ne pouvait pas reprendre
les 3000 milliards qu'on a des mises sur
la table en mars 2015
donc on a roulé ce terreau jusqu'en 2021
et là on nous explique qu'on va ont
probablement en mettre un autre sur pied
encore plus massif et avec des taux
encore plus favorable puisqu'il se rêve
25 points de base en dessous du taux
actuel autrement dit on serait carrément
dans un refinancement à tous négatifs
voilà donc c'est d'être là qui les
payent en vérité ça va être tout le
monde parce que quand on quand on va
sortir 1500 milliards comme l'a fait la
fed plus de 800 milliards de curieux
mais seuls 800 milliards c'est qu'un
chiffre provisoire ça plus haut ça
pourrait peut-être être 2 milliards dans
un mois personne ne remboursera ça
contre cela va affaiblir naturellement
les monnaies dans un premier temps on
veut en bus dès la dépression on veut
pas d'un scénario à la vénézuélienne ou
à l'argentine
c'est ça qu'on va essayer d'empêcher
dans un premier temps on va avoir un
choc déflationniste
néanmoins puisque les gens peuvent pas
consommer mais dans un deuxième temps
toute cette monnaie que l'on va sortir
elle fera pas remboursé à mon avis mais
c'est simplement que ça va déprécier la
monnaie en même temps qu'on déprécie la
monnaie bon là effectivement on assèche
la dette alors que quand la monnaie perd
de sa valeur on rembourse en monnaie de
singe et ça c'est un peu la solution
indolore
nestlé indolore le cas certain temps
parce que dans un deuxième temps tout
cet argent créé va se transformer en
inflation donc en perte de pouvoir
d'achat de cette monnaie donc quelque
part la monnaie qu'on va créer
on peut en créer
et 2000 milliards moi j'ai même entendu
parler de famine milliards de la part de
spécialistes des marchés obligataires
s'il pense que le grand risque
effectivement fait un éclatement de la
bulle des dettes corporate attentes des
entreprises et que pour empêcher cet
éclatement
il faudra probablement mettre
probablement m 5000 milliards dans les
trains on les mettra mais ultérieurement
ces familles milliards ce s'évaporeront
sous forme d'inflation et on aura une
inflation qui effectivement correspondra
à une sorte de deux chocs en retour ou
de phénomènes newtonien de destruction
de la monnaie merci philippe béchade
d'avoir été avec nous pour cette analyse
économique en direct donc sur un rt
france en pleine crise du coronavirus et
l'allemagne est donc le troisième pays
européen le plus touché après l'italie
et l'espagne dans cette crise il y
actuellement plus de 6000 cas confirmés
de coronavirus avec 14 décès le pays a
donc décidé d'employer les grands moyens
pour tenter d'endiguer la propagation de
cette épidémie des contrôles de police
renforcés elles sont mis en place les
précisions de km en ski tels les rues de
berlin sont désertes théâtre lieux de
culte ou encore aires de jeu sont
désormais fermés pour contenir la
pandémie de coronavirus la chancelière
allemande a décidé en concertation avec
les länder de durcir les consignes
nous avons fermé ou fermeront sous peu
toutes les écoles jardin d'enfants à
l'échelle de l'état dans tous les états
aujourd'hui nous avons décidé de
nouvelles directives avec tous les
lander
désormais voitures et piétons sont
contrôlés par des policiers allemands
mais les berlinois sont résignés à voir
leur vie figer le temps de la
quarantaine
je trouve qu'il est nécessaire de passer
à l'étape supérieure pendant un mois
jusqu'à ce que nous en sachions plus
qu'à nous savons pas encore ce qu'il va
se passer
donc je trouve ça bien si aucune mesure
n'avait été prise
il y aurait eu beaucoup de colère car
nous n'aurions rien faire maintenant
nous prenons des précautions pour
limiter les dégâts autant que possible
peut-être que cela aidera depuis 8
heures ce matin les entrées chez nos
voisins germaniques sont réduites au
strict minimum
ce les travailleurs frontaliers sont
autorisés à se rendre outre-rhin
le président fédéral allemand appelle la
population à rester chez soi avec de
sommation soyons responsables
soyons solidaires et le groupe des sept
qui promet de tout faire pour restaurer
la croissance dans un communiqué commun
publié cet après midi les dirigeants du
g7 explique dans tout faire pour
soutenir immédiatement les travailleurs
les entreprises et des secteurs les plus
touchés par la crise les pays disent
mobilisés des instruments de politique
économique et à leur disposition que ce
soit des mesures budgétaires et
monétaires dans des actions ou des
actions ciblées pour restaurer la
croissance mondiale
ça leur a plu à proposer à d'introduire
une restriction des déplacements non
essentiels vers l'union et ce pendant
les 30 prochains jours écouté
nous considérons que ces déplacements ne
sont pas essentiels et qu'il faut les
éviter dans la mesure du possible pour
enrayer la propagation du virus
dans l'union et en dehors de l'union en
évitant ses déplacements non essentiels
nous limitons aussi le fardeau qui pèse
sur l'eau structures hospitalières
il y aura évidemment des dérogations
pour les ressortissants européens qui
rentrent chez eux pour les travailleurs
de la santé comme les médecins les
infirmières qui travaillent à la
résolution de cette crise sanitaire opus
les afters qui doivent travailler de
l'autre côté de la frontière
seront également exemptés
l italie le pays d'europe qui paye le
plus lourd tribut à la pandémie
qui a dépassé la barre des 2000 morts là
bas avec 349 décès dans les dernières 24
heures en plus le gouvernement italien
qui a adopté aujourd'hui un décret
contenant des mesures d'un montant
d'environ 25 milliards d'euros
il s'agit notamment de soutenir les
familles et les entreprises touchés par
la pandémie elle ces mesures
supplémentaires doivent être adoptées en
avril écouter le premier ministre
italien au sein de couy l'émission et
justin et disputes l'état et les autres
à des mesures de relance et la coppa
déclin des prochaines fêtes de la
présence de l'état
nous proposons une réponse ou le réflexe
dans le domaine économique nous avons
été les premiers à mettre quelque chose
comme 1 5 milliard d'eurps et sophie du
système économique italien et au profit
des entreprises et des familles
nous allons activer des flux pour un
total de 350 milliards d'euros
il s'agit d'une mesure économique
majeure du côté de la population face
aux mesures de sécurité prises par le
gouvernement pour endiguer le virus
notamment dans les supermarchés les
italiens se conforme aux demandes
écouter les gens respectent les règles
espérons que cela aidera mais j'espère
qu'il y aura toujours de la nourriture
disponible parce que c'est déjà assez
triste et ce serait pire
ici un supermarché nous gardons les
distances de sécurité tels et travailler
je suis venu ici pour acheter un
sandwich mais toujours avec les
précautions nécessaires
j'ai des gants dans ma poche je respecte
calmement manille mais j'essaie d'être
aussi rapide que possible je crois que
dans ce genre de situation nous devons
être complaisant et ordonnée
[Musique]
je vois que les gens réagissent
positivement j'espère que cela se
terminera bientôt parce que je suis
épuisé mais pour paula moss cardinaux
journaliste reporter pour la chaîne
italienne l'a7 les pays européens
doivent apporter une réponse coordonnée
pour vaincre l'épidémie chez les souris
de d'un côté des mesures strictes comme
une situation c'est que vous êtes
difficile 7
hier élus tablette maintenant à bien
utiliser le nier ne pourra se battre sur
tous les européens à garder la mesure
stricte vérité
en italie la situation est très
préoccupante notamment dans le nord car
celui-là qui est l'épicentre de la fin
des misères au sud du pays fut il ya des
cas il y avait très peu de cas en tout
cas mais jusqu'à ce que beaucoup de
personnes plus de cinquante mille
personnes se déplacent du nord vers le
sud pour retrouver la famille semaine
après ceux de grandes transhumances
non non ce déplacement massif
le nombre des cas a commencé à augmenter
cela notre lien à l'importance de ce
confinement et dans ce contexte
l'espagne annonce la fermeture de ses
frontières terrestres afin de contenir
l'expansion du coronavirus selon le
ministère de l'intérieur le pays recense
près de 1500 nouveaux car en 24 heures
et le confinement de 15 jours risque de
durer françois xavier lambert
des rames de métro quasiment déserté la
capitale espagnole prend des allures de
ville fantôme alors que l'espagne et
placées en état d' alerte dans les rues
les forces de l'ordre se déploient en
nombre pour faire appliquer les mesures
de confinement qui sont entrées en
vigueur à minuit pour 15 jours des
militaires ont été déployés dans 14
villes pour aider au nettoyage et faire
respecter les restrictions de
circulation
nous devons être conscients que cela ne
doit pas nous faire paniquer ni nous
faire prendre des mesures extrêmes ce
qu'on doit faire c'est être responsable
et nos responsabilités commence par
prendre des mesures d'hygiène suffisante
et les mesures de distanciation sociale
demande et nous ne devrons pas nous
inquiéter au delà de ça pourtant
certains refusent encore de se plier aux
injonctions des autorités
dans la station balnéaire de benidorm la
police locale a dû intervenir face à des
touristes attablé en terrasse des
consignes non respectées également dans
la gare d'atocha à madrid où des
centaines de passagers se sont pressés
ce matin les mesures drastiques met
aussi les entreprises à l'arrêt faute de
pièces détachées les constructeurs
automobiles renault seat nissan et ps en
suspendu leurs usines espagnoles
le gouvernement vient d'annoncer la
fermeture des frontières terrestres
tréport à nicolas klain spécialiste de
l'espagne contemporaine les mesures
radicales prises en espagne arrive un
peu tard on le gouvernement espagnol de
pedro sanchez a réagi très tardivement
même bien avant cette annonce de la
fermeture des frontières terrestres
il y a encore un peu plus d'une semaine
le dimanche 8 mars il inciter les gens à
venir manifester dans les rues pour la
journée mondiale des droits des femmes
alors qu' il y avait des ddc le très
fort est fortement déconseillé à la fois
par l'union européenne et par les
autorités scientifiques espagnols que
beaucoup de partis de personnalités
demandé que c'est manifestation soit
déprogrammé et globalement le
gouvernement pedro sanchez a
malheureusement est très très tardive
dans ses réponses alors depuis quelques
jours on voit un emballement et une
radicalisation des mesures qui sont
prises mais elles n'arrivent le bal mans
tard ce qui est
des costumes la gravité de la situation
dans le pays le liban confinement
jusqu'au 29 mars et l'annoncé du
gouvernement ces dernières heures
l'épidémie du corona virus qui touche
une centaine de personnes dans le pays
les précisions de médiers ce qui fit
face à une épidémie qui touche le monde
entier le liban se plaçant confinement
et ferme ses aéroports
le nouveau gouvernement libanais vient
d'annoncer un plan interdisant aux
habitants de sortir de chez eux avec une
centaine d'oeufs contaminés confirmé
l'exécutif ne veut prendre aucun risque
déclarons la mobilisation générale avec
l'émission de la présence ordonnance
datée du 15 novembre 2020
jusqu'au 29 mars 2000 va à minuit pour
mettre en oeuvre les plans suivants les
résidents doivent rester chez eux et ne
pas sortir sauf en cas d'extrême urgence
car cela un effet négatif sur la
propagation de la pandémie confirmer
toutes les mesures prises pour lutter
contre le coronavirus en interdisant les
rassemblements dans les lieux publics et
privés jeudi dernier le liban avait
signalé son troisième des séries aux
communes 19 et dans la foulée avait
arrêté les vols en provenance des pays
les plus touchés par la pandémie
le président michel aoun appelle les
citoyens s'isoler pour empêcher la
propagation de la maladie
il exhorte les travailleurs à exercer à
domicile en déclarant l'état d'urgence
médicale alors que le pays traverse sa
pire crise économique et financière
depuis des décennies la peine est double
pour la population les mesures qui sont
prises par l'état aujourd'hui sont
suffisantes mais elles ont été prises
depuis longtemps depuis le début de la
propagation du coronavirus si celui ci
est limitée par la fermeture des boîtes
de nuit des restaurants des centres
commerciaux
si dieu le veut cela conduira de bons
résultats
toutes les frontières libanaises vont
donc être fermé au même titre que les
ports et les aéroports à compter de
mercredi de nouvelles mesures sont
attendues d'ici la fin du mois
fermeture des frontières marais
restaurant qui baissent le rideau de
l'argent débloqué en urgence par
certains pays
la pandémie de kobe de 19 à déstabiliser
la planète toute entière retour en
images sur les faits marquants de ces
dernières heures a ainsi signé à des
lames et medjahed le coronavirus change
les habitudes dans le golf de dubaï à
koweit city en passant par doha
la peur de la maladie bouleverse les
habitudes les salutations à distance et
les prières à domicile sont désormais de
mise fini pour un temps le shopping dans
les môles ou la chicha entre amis dans
les cafés plus de 3 milliards d'euros
ont été débloqués par la russie les
autorités ont annoncé une série de
mesures pour soutenir l'économie et
lutter contre la propagation d'une
couronne à virus est la ville de moscou
a annoncé aussi la fermeture dès samedi
prochain de toutes les écoles fermeture
jusqu'à nouvel ordre des cafés
restaurants salles de théâtre et de
cinéma au maroc et des mesures
drastiques qui concerne aussi les salles
de sport hammam salle de jeu les souks
les commerces et les locaux de vente de
produits et matières de première
nécessité reste en revanche ouverts tout
premier cas de contamination par le
coronavirus au libéria il s'agit du chef
de l' agence environnementale du pays de
retour de suisse la tanzanie et la
somalie ont aussi enregistré ce lundi
leur première contamination à la maladie
la liste des pays qui ferment leurs
frontières s'allonge
parmi les derniers et à prendre cette
mesure la république tchèque la
slovaquie l'ukraine la russie la bolivie
le paraguay l'argentine ou encore le
pérou et le venezuela a placé de son
côté sept de ces états dont au quart à
casal isolement quasi total
les habitants doivent rester confinés
chez eux sauf pour des raisons de
première nécessité toute la suisse est
en état d'urgence jusqu'au 19 avril
prochain seuls les commerces de première
nécessité reste ouvert et genève
interdit de son côté les rassemblements
de plus de cinq personnes
on le rappelle le canton héberge de
nombreuses organisations internationales
dont le siège européen de
enfin le box-office nord-américain a
enregistré ce week-end ses plus mauvais
résultats depuis vingt ans les salle se
vide par crainte de la propagation du
coronavirus c'est la fin de cette
émission rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans quelques instants pour un point
complet sur l'actualité du jour
[Musique]
non
peu plus
nous
peu plus qu'eux
beaucoup
oh
[Musique]
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés les contempler ces découvrir le
regard que portent les artistes sur leur
époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet et sept
enfants couverts de toute la tendresse
de sa mère peint par elisabeth vigée
lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
il y a une problématique de
documentation extrêmement importante de
la demande en eau depuis la révolution
verte qui a conduit à cette
autosuffisance alimentaire de l'inde
dans ces zones climatiques aride il ya
quasiment plus d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
pomper ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image une femme qui porte un pot à
eau sur la tête et une image que l'on
voit partout pour les femmes c'est une
charge énorme des petites filles peuvent
pas aller à l'école parce que doivent
aider à cette tâche par exemple donc ça
accentue des inégalités 85% de l'eau
consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pour être produite à l'échelle mondiale
d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire l'eau qui
est contenu dans les produits qui sont
échangées l'inde est un des plus gros
exportateurs d'eau donc c'est un
paradoxe en soi
sa ville écrit des livres et ça c'était
un peu votre vote secret votre ambition
secrète catonné actrice à un moment
donné il faut faire autre chose il faut
prendre la parole
il faut dire que je et comment mieux
qu'en écrivant votre livre raconte
l'histoire dont de vania vassia de leur
fille sonia by sonia c'est un peu vous
serez pu être vous je voulais que ce
soit très passionnant et je voulais en
même temps faire un examen s de bilan de
ce que j'avais vécu le passé c'est comme
une boucle ça peut aussi être un
réservoir pour des données d'avenir vous
êtes un marqueur de l'immigration
heureux quelque part vous êtes d'accord
qu'est ce qui vous a sauvé
qu'est ce qui vous a boosté écoutez
c'est la curiosité c'est quand même ça
la france c'est que c'est un tremplin
pour ceux qui veulent réussir
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même dit
que quand la vie de l'un trop dure il
faut se rendre dans un cimetière
ouadhias salam est immense c'est le plus
grand cimetière monde l'irak abrite le
plus grand cimetière au monde argent
terre les morts c'est notre vie les
fossoyeurs de père en fils de ouadhias
salam sont les ultimes témoins des
conflits armés survenus en irak 20 ans
de paix on n'enterre pas beau puis nous
deux personnes peut-être il y avait plus
de travail pendant la guerre triesman
terrain glissements de terrain de mon
côté on lui sort diodes sorte de la cie
du fini enterré
[Musique]
on nous appelle les fils du cimetière
les fossoyeurs
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes en guerre en guerre
sanitaire l'ennemi est là invisible
emmanuel macron s'est donc adressé à 20h
aux français sur la crise du coronavirus
le président exemple la population à des
sacrifices et à limiter ses déplacements
dès demain midi pour une durée de 15
jours parmi les autres mesures annoncées
toutes les réformes en cours suspendus
dont celle des retraites quel report du
second tour des élections municipales on
dénombre aujourd'hui 6633 cas et 148
morts en paix les frontières à l'entrée
de l'union européenne et de schengen
seront fermées dès mardi midi comme l'a
précisé le président de la république le
g7 qui s'est tenue en sommet
extraordinaire par visio
conférence évoque une tragédie humaine
et plaide pour une extraordinaire sion
sur la gestion des frontières alors que
l'espagne elle annonce fermé les siennes
le bilan d'épidémie dépasse les 7000
personnes dans le monde dont
ils sont 58 rien pour lutter les 40
membres du g7 qui sont se sont dits
déterminés à faire tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour restaurer la croissance
mondiale alors une fois de plus les
bourses sont en chute libre
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron qui a donc
appelé à la responsabilité de chaque
français le président a annoncé
plusieurs mesures pour lutter contre les
coronavirus notamment des déplacements
fortement réduit elle pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec notre
reporter et celle farge et sel vous avez
suivi ce discours vous vous trouvez
devant l'elysée que faut-il en retenir
nous sommes un hangar à sanitaire contre
le court aux navires us a martelé le
chef de l'état pendant son allocution
une prise de parole d'une vingtaine de
minutes pendant laquelle le chef de
l'état annoncé une série de mesures pour
lutter contre le coc vide 19 je vous
demande des sacrifices pour ralentir
l'épidémie a déclaré emmanuel macron il
a tout d'abord à saluer les premières
mesures mises en place jeudi dernier le
chef de l'état qui a déploré que
certains français n'avait pas respecté
les gestes barrières et les consignes
sanitaires
dès demain à midi des consignes plus
strictes seront donc mis en place les
réunit
on familiale les réunions amicales ne
seront plus est permise les déplacements
seront fortement réduits je voudrais
écouter le chef de l'état j'ai décidé de
renforcer encore les mesures pour
réduire nos déplacements et nos contacts
au strict nécessaire dès demain midi et
pour quinze jours au moins nos
déplacements seront très fortement
réduit cela signifie que les
regroupements extérieur les réunions
familiales ou amicales ne seront plus
permises se promener retrouver ses amis
dans le parc dans la rue ne sera plus
possible
il s'agit de limiter au maximum ses
contacts au delà du foyer partout sur le
territoire français en métropole comme
outre-mer seules doivent demeurer les
trajets nécessaire nécessaire pour aller
faire ses courses avec de la discipline
et en mettant les distance d'au moins un
mètre en ne serrant pas la main en
embrassant pas les trajets nécessaire
pour se soigner
évidemment les trajets nécessaire pour
aller travailler quand le travail à
distance n'est pas possible et les
trajets nécessaires pour faire un peu
d'activité physique mais sans retrouver
là encore des amis ou des proches et
c'est donc au gouvernement que revient à
la tâche dans la soirée de préciser
modalités d'application de ces nouvelles
mesures à noter que dès mardi les
frontières de l'union européenne et de
l'espace schengen seront fermés une
décision commune entre européens a
précisé emmanuel macron écoutez nous
sommes en guerre aussi comme je voulais
dit jeudi pour nous protéger et contenir
la dissémination du virus mais aussi
préserver nos systèmes de soins nous
avons pris ce matin entre européens
une décision commune dès demain midi les
frontières à l'entrée de l'union
européenne et de l'espace schengen
seront fermés concrètement tous les
voyages entre les pays non européens et
l'union européenne seront suspendues
pendant 30 jours
les françaises et les français qui sont
actuellement à l'étranger et souhaite
rentrer pourront bien entendu rejoindre
leur pays
maquereau qui précise que toutes les
réformes en cours sont suspendues même
sort pour le second tour des élections
municipales qui est donc supporter cette
charge en direct de l'elysée pour relier
maisto président de sud radio
emmanuel macron était à la hauteur des
attentes des français
cic et il était temps à la hauteur de la
situation
il était sobre sur la forme juste sur le
fond et je pense que l'heure est à
l'union nationale
il la suit i lui-même un effort
individuel et annie un effort collectif
en se hisser à la bonne hauteur cette
situation tout à fait exceptionnelle et
donc ce soir et je pense le discours
qu'il fallait prononcé et le discours
qu'il fallait que tout le monde entende
pour que chacun prenne la mesure et
fassent preuve de responsabilité dans
ses déplacements
parce que parfois on n'a pas
l'impression d'y échapper
on a l'impression nous mêmes que nous ne
sommes pas atteint mais nous sommes un
facteur de propagation parce que le
virus
ne circule pas dans l'absolu ce sont les
personnes humaines qui devront circuler
donc ce soir c'était vraiment le
discours qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
prônons et place au direct ont écouté le
ministre de l'intérieur après
l'allocution d'emmanuel macro sont forts
ces volontaires elles sont exigeantes
nous le savons mais ces mesures sont
nécessaires surtout essentiel pour
protéger toutes les françaises et tous
les français pas seulement les personnes
les plus âgées est essentielle pour
bloquer la propagation de ce virus pour
éviter à tout prix la surcharge de notre
système de santé essentiels pour
combattre le coc vie de 19 et limiter au
maximum le nombre de ses victimes
les mesures annoncées par le président
de la république jeudi puis par le
premier ministre samedi et est d'ores et
déjà des étapes majeures
je tiens à mon tour a salué toutes
celles et tous ceux qui par esprit de
responsabilité ont pris leurs
dispositions ont pris la mesure de la
situation
cependant le constat est lourd mais il
s'impose
la progression du coc vide 19 continue
est trop de personnes font encore peu de
cas des consignes sanitaires données il
n'ya pourtant aucun panache à ne pas
appliquer les gestes barrière aucune
gloire à se refuser aux mesures
sanitaires demandée est de venir
de par son comportement un allié du
virus un danger pour soi un danger pour
les autres aussi dès demain midi pour
une durée de quinze jours qui pourrait
être prolongé des mesures de restriction
ferme des déplacements ont été prises le
mot d'ordre est clair
restez chez vous il s'agit de mesures de
confinement sur le modèle de ce que nos
voisins espagnols ou italiens en mise en
place
ce que le président de la république a
décrit ce sont les mesures les plus
restrictives aujourd'hui en vigueur en
europe
nous menons un combat nous le ferons
respecter
toutefois l'activité de notre pays ne
doit pas s'arrêter totalement d
exception pourront être toléré pour les
déplacements entre le domicile et le
lieu de travail lorsque ces déplacements
sont indispensables pour des activités
ne pouvons être interrompue ni organisé
sous forme de télétravail pour les
déplacements nécessaires pour faire des
courses ou pour les besoins de première
nécessité je pense aux aliments aux
produits aux produits de premiers rygiel
pour les déplacements pour motifs de
santé bien sûr pour les déplacements
pour motif familial un père lieu où pour
l'assistance de personnes vulnérables
pour venir en aide à un proche dépendant
par exemple ou pour des parents séparés
pour aller chercher et déposer les
enfants d'autres exceptions pourront
être permise pour des déplacements
bref à proximité des domiciles on pourra
toujours pratiquer une activité physique
ou sortir son chien mais chacun devra le
faire avec parcimonie dont le respect
des consignes sanitaires et des gestes
barrières sans se retrouver en groupe
si je devais le résumer je dirais que
l'on pourra prendre l'air oui mais
certainement pas joué un match de foot
dans tous les cas la consigne générale
est simple c'est rester chez vous alors
je ne l'ignorent pas cette consigne
c'est renoncer au déplacement
touristique il ya bien des loisirs s'est
prononcé à voir ses amis c'est renoncer
au déjeuner ou au dîner en famille c'est
renoncer aux activités associatives
lorsqu'elle ne contribue pas à des
missions d'assistance aller pique-niquer
dans un parc ou dans un square
c'est interdit se retrouver en groupe
pour jouer c'est interdit ce sont autant
de sacrifices mais je crois qu'on peut
tous les comprendre et les faire quand
il s'agit au fond de sauver des vies y
compris la vôtre
comme celle de vos proches un dispositif
de contrôle sera mise en place par les
forces de l'ordre
il reposera sur des contrôles et des
points de contrôle fixes mais aussi des
points de contrôles mobiles à la fois
sur les axes principaux mais aussi sur
les axes secondaires
partout sur le territoire national il
mobilisera plus de cent mille policiers
et gendarmes dès ce soir je donne
l'ordre aux forces de sécurité
intérieure de se déployer sur le terrain
et de préparer la mise en place des
contrôles
toutes les personnes qui circuleront
devons être en mesure de justifier leurs
déplacements cela concerne évidemment
aussi les piétons
pour y parvenir chaque personne pour
chaque déplacement devra se munir d'un
document attestant sur l'honneur le
motif de son déplacement
cette installation sera obligatoire elle
sera téléchargeable en ligne dans la
nuit sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur est progressivement sur
l'ensemble des sites publics et bien au
delà je le souhaite
il appartiendra à chacun de le remplir
pour préciser la nature de son
déplacement
ces destinations et ses raisons ceux qui
disposent de cartes professionnelles ou
de certificats de leurs employeurs
pourront être amenés à les présenter
lors des contrôles leurs cartes pourront
aussi servir lieu d'attestation ce sera
notamment le cas par exemple des cartes
de presse
car l'information jouera un rôle
essentiel aussi dans le combat contre le
virus
enfin cette association pourra être
également réalisée sur papier libre
pour ceux qui ne disposent pas d'une
imprimante ou d'un accès à internet
la violation de ces règles est
actuellement puni d'une amende de
l'ordre de 38 euros
elle sera portée très rapidement à un
niveau supérieur qui pourrait être de
135 euros
notre objectif n'est pas de sanctionner
mais d'en appeler à la responsabilité de
tous notre objectif n'est pas de
sanctionner mais de montrer un civisme
collectif pour surmonter la crise notre
objectif n'est pas de sanctionner
mais s'il le faut nous le ferons
mesdames et messieurs cette épidémie
vous le savez intervient alors même que
la république traverse un moment
démocratique importante
les élections municipales jeudi dernier
après la consultation des différentes
forces politiques et les autorités
médicales
le président de la république avait
annoncé le maintien du premier tour des
élections municipales et communautaires
je les dis hier soir le premier tour
s'est déroulé dans de bonnes conditions
les électeurs on est accueilli dans tous
les bureaux de vote du pays dans des
conditions d'organisation particulière
respectant les recommandations
sanitaires émise le premier tour a
permis d'élire les conseillers
municipaux de plus de 30 mille de nos
communes ce qui représente environ 65%
des 43 millions d'électeurs que compte
notre pays
l'organisation remarquable mise en place
et je veux ici a à nouveau salué la
rigueur et l'engagement des maires élus
candidats et fonctionnaires qui ont
contribué à cette réussite mais aussi le
civisme des électeurs et cela va
permettre qu'à la fin de cette semaine
les conseils municipaux puissent
désigner 30000 mère dans notre pays
les élections qui ont été conclusive à
l'issue du premier tour sont acquises
nul ne comprendrait en effet que les
résultats réguliers d'élections
organisées conformément aux lois de la
république et qui ont permis de pourvoir
à l'issue du premier tour
les conseils municipaux soit remise en
cause c'est l'expression de la volonté
du peuple
c'est le respect aussi que nous devons
au suffrage universel
toutefois pour environ 5000 communes les
résultats du premier tour exige
l'organisation d'un second tour de
scrutin pour cette commune
un second tour sera organisé il doit
l'être et il le sera
le président de la république a indiqué
tout à l'heure que les expertises
scientifiques sollicité conduisent à
reporter l'organisation du second tour
dans les 5000 communes où sa tenue est
nécessaire il a consulté ce jour les
présidents des assemblées le 1er mai
il sera également consulter les
représentants des forces politiques du
pays et il était apparu qu'un consensus
existe et sur la nécessité de reporter
le second tour de l'élection municipale
cela sur ce double fondement à la fois
l'expertisé médicale d'une part et le
consensus politique d'autre part deux
textes seront pris ils permettront de
tenir compte de la condi de l'as des
circonstances sanitaire exceptionnelle
que nous vivons et organiseront le
report du second tour des élections
municipales et communautaires dans les
communes où il devait se tenir un décret
pris en conseil des ministres dès demain
abrogera la convocation des électeurs
pour le second tour des élections
municipales et communautaires qui était
prévu samedi 22 mars un projet de loi
qui sera examiné lui aussi des deux
mêmes et par le conseil d'état et
mercredi par le conseil des ministres
organisera le report de ce scrutin à une
date ultérieure au plus tard au mois de
juin
ce projet de loi prévoira que dans un
délai de six semaines au plus c'est à
dire dans le courant du mois de mai un
rapport du conseil scientifique créée
pour la gestion de la crise sanitaire du
courant des virus statuera sur la
possibilité au plan sanitaire
d'organiser les élections un horizon de
six semaines
c'est à dire à compter de la mi juin
évidemment nous présenterons ce rapport
d expertise à l'ensemble des forces
politiques de notre pays
espérer quelques nous prendrons la
décision précise du choix de maintenir
et du choix de la date qui est possible
d'ici la fin du mois de juin
nous déterminerons précisément cela avec
l'ensemble des partis politiques
léger ans de demain soir 18 heures ne
s'applique donc pas celle qui fait que
les candidats qui veulent concourir pour
le second tour présentent leur
candidature
le délai donc pour déposer les
candidatures sera repoussée par le
projet de loi
concrètement pour organiser le second
tour
le projet de loi comprendra plusieurs
mesures fortes
il confirmera que les conseillers
municipaux communautaires élu dès le
premier tour entre
en fonction immédiatement pour les
communes où le premier tour n'a pas été
conclusif le projet de loi prévoira que
le mandat des conseillers municipaux et
des mères sera prolongée par la loi
autant que nécessaire les maires et les
conseils municipaux en place
administreront les communes jusqu'à ce
que le second tour soit tenue dans les
communautés de communes communautés
d'agglomération métropole ces
intercommunalités qui organise bien
souvent les services publics essentiels
à la population nous prévoirons un
régime spécifique répondant au caractère
exceptionnel de notre situation ce
régime vers à coexister dans une période
limitée dans une même intercommunalité à
la fois les nouveaux élus dont
l'élection était acquise au 1er tour
ainsi que les élus dont le mandat aurait
été prolongée il sera a proposé et
organisé dans ces collectivités
une élection d'un président et d'un
exécutif dont le mandat sera limité
jusqu'à ce que le renouvellement général
des élus aient pu intervenir une fois
les élections hvl nouvel exécutif sera
mise en place le projet de loi
habilitera le gouvernement à prendre par
ordonnance les mesures nécessaires à
l'organisation du report de ce second
tour
celles ci concernent notamment les
modalités de financement des campagnes
de tenues de liste et d'autres questions
techniques relatives à l'organisation du
report du second tour
cet ensemble de mesures sera traduit
dans les textes qui seront déposés
immédiatement au parlement ainsi aux
côtés de l'état les collectivités
pourront jouer tout leur rôle dans les
jours qui viennent car nous avons besoin
d'elle et nous savons toute l'importance
des services publics essentiels qu'elle
administre pour nos concitoyens
c'est pourquoi nous avons aussi veiller
à ce que leur continuité soit garanti
tout comme la continuité des services
publics qu'elle administre pourra être
assurée enfin le président de la
république a annoncé tout
jour dans le même et unique objectif de
freiner la propagation du virus
des mesures concernant nos frontières
tout comme il est nécessaire de rester
chez soi les déplacements
transfrontaliers doivent être réduits
comme les autres au strict est
nécessaire minimum pour réussir notre
action ne peut s'inscrire que dans le
cadre d'une réponse globale européenne
qu'il s'agisse des frontières
extérieures de l'europe ou des
frontières nationales au sein de l'union
européenne
c'est pourquoi ces derniers jours le
président de la république a échangé
avec ses homologues avec la présidente
de la commission européenne et le
président du conseil européen
j'ai été en contact étroit avec mes
homologues des pays européens ainsi
qu'avec la commissaire aux affaires
intérieures ce matin même nous avions
avec la commission et les ministres de
l'intérieur de l'union européenne une
visioconférence pour harmoniser nos
actions permettez-moi de revenir sur ce
sujet également évoqué ce soir par le
président de la république
premièrement s'agissant des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne alors
que nous mettons tout en oeuvre au
niveau européen pour contenir la commune
a sion la contamination du coc vide 19
nous devons veiller à empêcher les
mouvements internationaux qui pourraient
renforcer la pandémie c'est la raison
pour laquelle la france appuie les
propositions présentées cet après-midi
même par la présidente de la commission
européenne les entrées de tous les
ressortissants étrangers dans l'espace
schengen sont proscrites
cela signifie que seuls les citoyens des
états membres de l'espace schengen et de
l'union européenne
elle sait que les ressortissants du
royaume uni qui reste soumis dans la
période de transition du break site au
droit européen pourront entrer dans
notre espace de circulation commune
les ressortissants des pays tiers qui
dispose d'un permis de séjour européen
pourront également continuer d'accéder à
l'espace européen
quelques autres exceptions seront
aménagés pour les personnels de santé
ressortissants des pays tiers par
exemple
par ailleurs je veux le souligner la
circulation entrantes et sortantes de
marchandises
se poursuivra mais pour les
ressortissants de pays tiers qui n'ont
pas de raisons impératives de se rendre
en europe
alors ils feront l'objet d'une
interdiction d'entrée en limitant ainsi
les franchissement des frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne nous
limiterons la propagation de la pandémie
cette décision que la france prend en
accord avec la commission européenne
elle devra être prise de manière
identique et simultanée par l'ensemble
de nos partenaires européens
ce sera un véritable test pour l'europe
nous le devons aux citoyens européens
deuxièmement s'agissant des frontières
intérieures de l'union européenne
vous l'avez vu des mesures ont d'ores et
déjà été prises ces derniers jours pour
limiter les échanges que ce soit avec
l'italie l'allemagne air ou l'espagne
aujourd'hui
j'insiste il ne s'agit pas pour nous de
procéder à une fermeture totale des
frontières
il s'agit de limiter les échanges au
strict nécessaire
il ne faut plus de circulation
transfrontalière qui ne soit pas
indispensable
c'est cohérent avec les mesures de
confinement que nous prenons ainsi en
coordination avec mes homologues des
pays voisins
nous mettons en place des contrôles des
déplacements transfrontaliers non
nécessaire cela de part et d'autre de
nos frontières et en bonne coordination
avec les police aux frontières des pays
voisins
ceux qui n'auront pas vocation à
franchir ses frontières seront invités à
faire demi tour
en revanche je veux rassurer les
nombreux travailleurs transfrontaliers
sur la base de justificatifs de domicile
et d'emploi vous serez autorisé à
continuer de franchir les frontières que
vous franchissez quotidiennement et
c'est nécessaire de la même façon il est
hors de question de pénaliser le
transport de marchandises
quel qu'il soit l'approvisionnement de
matériel de soins ou encore en denrées
alimentaires ou de première nécessité ne
sera donc pas impactés par ces mesures
ce matin nous nous sommes entendus entre
ministres européens pour que ces mesures
soient bien proportionné
dûment concertée entre pays limitrophes
et notifiée à la commission européenne
mesdames et messieurs au début de cette
intervention j'ai employé les mots
combattre le kobe de 19 le président de
la république l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est bien une guerre que nous menons
contre le virus
une guerre qui mobilise tous les
personnels soignants tous les agents de
nos services publics
toutes les forces de sécurité
intérieures de notre pays une guerre qui
doit mobiliser tous les citoyens
français dans cette guerre chacun a sa
responsabilité
chacun a les moyens d'anticiper et de
participer aux combats
cela n'a jamais été aussi simple en
réalité il suffit de rester chez soi
nous devons avoir ni panique ni légèreté
nous devons agir ensemble faire
république respecté les consignes les
gestes barrière rester chez soi
l'épidémie de covin 19 nous concerne
tous et c'est ensemble et ensemble
seulement que nous pourront la surmonter
je vous remercie il ya des questions
bonjour monsieur le ministre à l'iss et
à saint-paul à vous venez d'entendre
l'allocution de christophe castaner qui
a donné les détails après le discours d'
emmanuel macron sur la conduite à tenir
pendant cette crise du coronavirus pour
plus d'explications on va les retrouver
celle farges notre reporter qui se
trouve devant l'elysée qui a suivi comme
nous d'ailleurs la locution christophe
castaner et celle que faut-il en retenir
est bien le mot d'ordre est clair 1
stéphanie il faut rester chez soi le
ministre de l'intérieur a fallu aussi en
tout cas d'emmanuel macro déploré le
comportement de certains français qui
n'avait pas respecté les mesures
barrières céder ces derniers jours
christophe castaner qui a déclaré que le
pays et ne pouvait cependant pas rester
à l'arrêt concernant lé déplacement et
bien certains seront autorisés pour
aller chez le médecin pour aller faire
ses courses pour prendre l'air dans le
respect qu à des mesures barrière un
dispositif de contrôle va être mise en
place par les forces de l'ordre partout
en france plus deux cent mille policiers
et gendarmes vont être mobilisés alors
il faudra justifier ses déplacements
avec une attestation sur l'honneur
téléchargeable sur le site du ministère
de l'intérieur tous ceux qui ne la
respecteraient pas ces règles pourront
être sanctionnés d'une amende de 38
euros pouvant aller jusqu'à 135 euros
alors christophe castaner à la préciser
l'objectif n'est pas de sanctionner mais
montrez incivisme collectif enfin à
concernant le second tour des élections
municipales christophe castaner tout
comme emmanuel macron a indiqué qu'il
serait reportée à une date ultérieure
et c'est bien une guerre que nous menons
contre le virus et chacun a les moyens
de participer au combat en restant chez
soi c'est par ces mots que christophe
castaner a terminé son allocution
merci et celle farges en direct de
l'elysée nous reviendrons bien bibis un
bien évidemment sur toutes ces mesures
les détails la mise en application dans
notre prochaine édition ce sera demain
matin 7 heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée est au sur rt
france
[Musique]
pardon